Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW. Unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Britlav und heute ist wieder Freitag, also ist wieder Corona Weekly, hallo Pabel.
Hallo Tim.
Die wöchentliche Abklapperung aller ganzen Zahlen und sonstigen Ereignisse, die uns hier im Kontext der Koruna-Krise so ereilen,
Ja und heute haben wir auf jeden Fall eine Menge zu erzählen. Das ist äh schon mal klar, unsere Notizenquellen geradezu über.
Volles Programm heute, deswegen gehen wir auch ein bisschen Gas.
Mhm. Noch einmal.
Und würde sagen, wir steigen gleich mal in die Zahlen ein und ich fand das eigentlich ganz gut, wie wir das auch beim letzten Mal gemacht haben, so kurzen Blick auf die Welt
zwo und dann irgendwo der Zoom runter nach nach Berlin.
Datum müssen wir natürlich noch sagen, zwanzigster November zwanzig zwanzig ist heute. Ja.
Freitag.
Und alle Zahlen sind veröffentlicht für diesen Tag nehme ich an.
Ja, das meiste und nicht aus allen Ländern, aber äh ja
aber doch müsste es eigentlich jetzt alles da. Wie es aussieht. Gut, auf der Welt hatten wir ja beim letzten Mal glaube ich schon
angekündigt, dass äh äh die USA äh bei den Neuerkrankungen Europa wieder überholen
werden und das ist auch deutlich eingetreten, sowohl in der EU als auch in Europa fallen nämlich die.
Neuerkrankungen ähm aber in der US, in den USA geht's steil nach oben,
So ähm ja ansonsten ja Russland geht auch sogar leicht zurück. Ähm,
Iran äh und Russland hatten deutliche Anstiege, aber haben jetzt heute,
äh äh relativ geringe wieder geringe Zahlen gemeldet. Und ja, sieht.
Amerika plätschert so vor sich hin, Tendenz ja gleichbleibend, leicht sinkend, so geht man immer wieder hoch und runter äh dort. Ja und äh was die
Welt angeht, bewegt sich das jetzt äh auch ja waagerecht, also weltweit ungefähr bleiben die Zahl
der Neuerkrankungen jetzt gleich so,
und in Afrika und Asien nach wie vor nichts los und sogar in Indien gehen die Zahlen äh zurück seit zwei Monaten ungefähr, also die Neuerkrankungen.
Ja, es ist wirklich ein westliches Problem derzeit. Das kann man echt nicht anders sagen.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Definitiv.
Kann man so sagen. Und in Europa jetzt fallen.
Auch die Länder so, ich würde sagen, in drei verschiedene Kategorien. Nach den habe ich die jedenfalls sortiert äh und da sind erstmal die Länder,
wo entweder die Zahlen deutlich am Fallen sind oder die Zahlen soweit.
Äh sind, dass man sagen kann, das ist jetzt nicht großartig, beunruhigend und sagen das schlechteste von den.
Ländern ist Polen äh so. Ähm in der Schweiz sehen wir auch jetzt se.
Ja zwei Wochen äh ungefähr äh einen äh ganz deutlichen Rückgang in Tschechien gehen die Zahlen seit drei Wochen zurück. So in Schweden,
sehr hat sich auch so seit zehn Tagen
äh der Rückgang weiter verstetigt in Belgien sind die Zahlen auch drastisch gefallen. Spanien sieht okay aus,
Holland immer.
Ja, hat sich jetzt so auf, ich sage mal, dreihundert äh auf eine Institanz von dreihundert runtergearbeitet. Ähm also halbiert, aber äh fällt halt nicht weiter,
In der Slowakei, wo sie ja den äh die halbe Bevölkerung getestet haben und die andere Hälfte in Quarantäne geschickt.
Gehen die Zahlen auch weiter runter, weil's kein so super drastischer Knick, aber scheint's halt auch gebracht zu haben und Monaco und ja, Irland, ganz leichter Anstieg, aber eine sehr niedrige Instit
Das ist so, ich sage mal die Liste der Länder, die äh ja äh definitiv auf einem positiven Weg.
Also
zu zu Slowenien, also ich weiß nicht, was du da siehst, aber die Kurve ähm geht ja auch wieder leicht hoch, also es gab zwar diesen deutlichen sehr
Knick in der Kurve, aber seitdem hat er sich nicht weiter verstätigt. Also das ist ähm.
Meinte die Slowakei jetzt.
Ach so, da habe ich jetzt Slowenien und Slowakei, der Klassiker äh miteinander verbunden. Äh okay, wo ist denn die.
Slowakei ist die Exhälfte von äh von der CSR.
Und Slowenien irgendwie so ein ja fast Stadtstaat gut bisschen größer aber Rest Jugoslawienrest
ähm so. Ne, deswegen, das ist dann in der potentiell dann einer der nächsten Gruppen,
Die zweite Ländergruppe äh ja, da ist auch Slowenien drin, ist, wo man sagen kann.
T, die haben sich halt stabilisiert. Das ist zwar nicht wirklich gut, also es geht da nicht runter so, aber es geht da auch nicht
mehr drastisch äh äh nach oben und halt sowas wie Luxemburg und,
Österreich, was vielleicht so ein über den Piek rüber ist, Slowenien schon richtig sagte, die sind zwar runtergegangen dann, aber seit
einer Woche, ja seit zehn Tagen oder so, steigt es da wieder ganz leicht. Rumänien auch relativ flach,
Frankreich,
auch äh ganz gut runtergekommen, wobei das da jetzt in den letzten Tagen stagniert. Schweden hat möglicherweise hoffentlich auch den Peak hinter sich allerdings, glaube ich, gab's da so gewisse,
Porting Probleme, Kosovo auch stabil UK. Da bewegt sich zwar nicht viel, aber äh so
tendenziell jetzt die letzten Tage auch eher nach unten ja Deutschland gehört auch in diese Gruppe, wo wir
wird's nicht mehr richtig viel Wachstum haben so beziehungsweise den Zahlen, aber da kommen wir später noch drauf, einen leichten Rückgang. Äh ja, Lettland, gut und dann natürlich.
Ja Norwegen,
Irland, Finnland hat mir schon gut, die hätten eigentlich eher in die andere Gruppe äh gehört, die, weil da heißt, sind die Institutionen so niedrig. Ähm.
Ja und dann vielleicht noch ein, oder wolltest du noch was dazu sagen, noch ein Blick auf unsere auf die europäischen Problemregionen.
Also äh ich wollte nur mal kurz anmerken, weil wir das letzte Mal auch vergessen haben und es wurde auch zu Recht äh angemerkt,
dass wir zwar uns äh und das hast du ja jetzt im Wesentlichen referiert die äh täglichen Fallzahlen
anschauen oder angeschaut haben oder jetzt interpretiert haben. Aber da gehört ja im Prinzip auch noch
eine zweite Zahl dazu, die man vielleicht anschauen sollte, nämlich wie groß die positiven Quote bei den Tests ist. Die ja eigentlich einen relativ.
Weil sie ein guter Indikator, aber zumindest ein Indikator ist, der sagt so, ja okay, sehen wir denn überhaupt alle Fälle, ne? Und Länder, die einfach eine extrem,
positiven Rate haben, also wo sozusagen.
Sehr viele von denen, die getestet werden, auch positiv sind. Das zeugt ja dann oft davon, dass man gar nicht so viel testet, also sehr viele Fälle nicht sieht.
Und wenn ich mir das jetzt gerade mal aufrufe,
Dann ist zum Beispiel das von mir erwähnte äh Slowenien ziemlich weit oben auch äh Rumänien, auch Österreich hat noch eine extrem hohe positiven Quote, also ungefähr so um die fünfundzwanzig Prozent herum, diese drei Länder.
Was einfach äh zu viel ist.
Und auch in Deutschland wahrscheinlich auch aus gutem Grund geht die Zahl ja auch nach oben. Und Schweden auch.
Ja. Mhm.
Das sind so Asp
die man auf jeden Fall nochmal mit berücksichtigen sollte, weil dieses Jahr wir haben ja wenig Fälle. Kann halt auch einfach an zu wenig Tests liegen, ne? Und wenn man so eine hohe positive Quote hat, dann äh sagt das einiges aus. Ich habe jetzt gerade äh gehört, dass
Nors Jacota, also diesen relativ nördlichen Staat der USA, sie jetzt gerade irgendwie bei einer positiven Quote von,
Sechsundsiebzig oder achtzig Prozent angekommen sei.
Holy Shit.
Ja, genau, Hoodieshit, weil das heißt im Prinzip sie sehen nicht auch nur ansatzweise, wie viele Fälle es wirklich gibt, weil sie einfach nicht genug neu zu testen.
Mhm. Ja. Die Schwierigkeit halt mit den Testdaten ist, die sind halt teilweise.
Nicht für alle Länder verfügbar und ja, ist aber ein guter Punkt, weil offensichtlich hat Hour World in Data jetzt irgendwie auch die von Deutschland mit drin.
Allerdings immer so mit 'ner Woche zurück oder so. Und.
Insofern ist das halt immer ein bisschen schwierig, weil also viele äh Testzahlen weit zurück
hängen und äh insofern, ja, aber ist ein guter Hinweis noch, also mal beim nächsten Mal vielleicht nochmal genaueren Blick drauf werfen, wobei wir das für Deutschland sowieso
machen werden.
Ja dann mach einfach weiter.
Ähm ja äh selbst die.
Schlimmen Länder, da ist jetzt nichts dabei, wo es jetzt wirklich komplett durch die Decke geht in Europa,
sondern dass es halt noch Luxemburg hat halt jetzt wieder mal eine deutliche Steigerung. Sacht Slowenien hat mich jetzt schon,
eigentlich auch in der vorigen Gruppe, da geht's tendenziell auch nach oben, Serbien ist so ein bisschen, also Serbien,
zeigt derzeit den stärksten Anstieg Portugal sieht auch nicht gut aus, als wenn die damals im Griff hätten, Kroatien arbeitet sich so langsam nach oben,
Ungarn ebenfalls und ja.
Polen nicht ganz so schlimm, Griechenland äh ja geht leider auch nach oben und Albanien auch und Dänemark und Istland ja und Lettland äh,
So da gehen die Zahlen hoch, aber wie gesagt, mit Ausnahme von Serbien,
sehe ich jetzt keinen wirklich krassen äh Anstieg, sondern die sind alle äh relativ flach und das macht sich eben dann auch äh wie gesagt in,
sinkenden Zahlen sowohl für die EU als auch für,
ja gesamteuropa bemerkbar, wo die Zahlen langsam runtergehen. Jedenfalls, was die Neuinfektion angeht, guckt man jetzt allerdings auf.
Die Zahl der Toten sieht es nicht ganz so schön aus, wobei auch in Belgien und in Tschechien, die ja die schlimmsten Ausbrüche,
hatten mittlerweile die Zahlen runtergehen.
Während sie beispielsweise in Slowenien, was wir gerade hatten, noch steigen, in Polen noch steigen
Ungarn ist noch gleichbleibend Schweiz, stagniert gerade. Ja, Frankreich war leichter Anstieg
Rumänien leichte Ansiege in Österreich starker Anstieg noch an der Zahl der Toten. Da sieht noch nicht nicht so aus, als wird's zum Stillstand kommen während bei Portugal erstmal äh ja
Ist ein bisschen Einhalt gebietet.
Leichter Rückgang, aber noch ein ja auf,
europäischen Durchschnittsniveau ähm Spanien sieht okay aus, Griechenland steigt deutlich. So.
Also, wenn man sich, wenn man sich das Liniengewitter so im Großen anschaut, kann man schon noch sagen.
Das nimmt alles noch kräftig zu. So, also das ist äh äh die Auswirkung der zweiten Welle äh sind noch nicht komplett
durchgespürt und wenn locker noch zwei, drei Wochen anhalten
bis sich da irgendwas Nennenswertes verbessert. Also selbst wenn jetzt die Fallzahlen insgesamt runtergehen und es nur so zwei, drei Länder gibt, die es gerade überhaupt nicht im Griff äh kriegen oder nicht in den Griff kriegen wollen. Ähm
insgesamt und das sieht man ja auch in Deutschland äh haben wir es einfach jetzt noch mit sehr hohen Sterberaten zu tun und das ist auf jeden Fall in der Summe alles schlimmer als das vorher war.
Definitiv und kommulativ äh sagen bei den Zahlen.
Wie viele Leute jetzt wo verstorben sind, ist Belgien äh nach wie vor Spitzenreiter vor Spanien UK.
Frankreich und mittlerweile Tschechien, wo man leider sagen muss, die haben in der zweiten Welle es äh leider ziemlich.
Verzock.
Das ist ja hatten wir auch schon mal angesprochen, dass ja, sagen wir mal, die einzig wirklich gut quantifizierbare Zahl mal ab.
Vergleichbar. Also auf jeden Fall besser vergleichbar als die Institzen definitiv.
Ja auch sagen wir mal qualifizierbar insofern als dass man sich was drunter vorstellen kann. Also äh Belgien hat jetzt tausenddreihundert Tote pro Million oder anders ausgedrückt, eins Komma drei Prozent der Bevölkerung.
Sind an dieser Krankheit verstorben.
So, das, das ist das ist die eigentliche Botschaft. Das ist Platz eins, ja. Spanien äh ist bei null Komma neun Prozent äh UK bei null Komma sieben sieben.
Frankreich null Komma sieben so zum Vergleich der Schnitt in der.
Europäischen Union liegt bei null Komma fünf Prozent oder Europa ein bisschen drunter insgesamt.
Wir sind in Deutschland mit null Komma eins fünf Prozent da noch.
Null Komma eins sechs zwo wenn man mit Rollover.
Stimmt. Terbier sogar eine, bin um eine Spalte falsch geraten. Ja genau genau.
So, das ist, das ist die Größenordnung, was was diese Krankheit bisher an Schaden angerichtet hat, davon ausgehend, dass man eben auch die meisten.
Gestorbenen äh auch richtig klassifiziert hat. Also es mag sicherlich ja immer noch Leute geben, die,
daran gestorben sind, ohne dass man's weiß und umgekehrt, aber pi mal Daumen, denke ich mal, gibt einem das schon einen ganz guten Eindruck, was hier Phase ist und es gibt vor allem einen sehr guten Eindruck davon, wie gut die Länder das jetzt insgesamt,
bewältigt haben, ja? Das viel besprochene Schweden zum Beispiel liegt da ganz klar an Platz.
Auch mit null Komma sechs Prozent, ne?
Richtig gut im Übrigen, um das auch mal vielleicht von der Seite äh zu sehen, ist äh Finnland und zwar nicht nur gerade jetzt, sondern Finnland,
kompletten Verlauf der Corona-Krise.
Eigentlich nie wirklich dramatische Verhältnisse gehabt. Was wirklich bemerkenswert ist, gerade weil sie ja, sagen wir mal.
Nimmt er diesen skandinavischen Raum immer gerne so als ein Kulturraum war, äh dass äh erfährt sich ja sicherlich einige nennenswerte Einschränkungen und.
Man hat da wohl relativ gut äh reagiert, so wie ich das gehört habe, habe nochmal ein bisschen äh nachgefragt.
Was halt äh sehr auffällig ist bei Finnland ist, dass es halt sich dabei auch wieder um eine Frau handelt, die da am Start ist, so eine ganz junge,
ähm das könnte geholfen haben, obwohl ich ihr das jetzt nicht komplett alleine zuschreiben möchte.
Dann schauen wir doch mal auf Deutschland.
Ja
Der Blick auf Deutschland. Ja, wir hatten heute einen neuen Tagesrekord bei den Neuinfektionen. Knapp dreiundzwanzigtausendsechshundert,
achtundvierzig Neuinfektionen wurden heute gemeldet.
Aber der sieben Tage Schnitt ist jetzt ganz leicht gesunken so in den letzten Tagen und wir sind jetzt so bei den,
war ja,
achtzehn etwas über achtzehntausend, achtzehn, halbtausend äh im Schnitt in den letzten äh sieben Tagen.
An Neuinfektionen und.
Dementsprechend ist jetzt der aus diesen Zahlen berechnete R-Wert, also auf Basis,
des Veröffentlichungsdatums nicht zu verwechseln mit dem RKIRW, die auf Schätzungen
und Voraussagen basieren und auf Anmeldedatum oder Krankungsdatum und nicht auf dem Veröffentlichungsdatum, wobei
der Unterschied im Moment nicht groß ist, also auch die offiziellen RKI-Zahlen weisen gerade denselben R-Wert und auch dieselbe Prognose
eigentlich aus, dass wir,
ganz knapp unter eins liegen, also null Komma neun neun so nach meiner Lieblingsberechnungsmethode.
Tatsächlich, weil sich das Testregime geändert hat, müssen wir irgendwo zwischen fünf,
bis zehn Prozent eigentlich obendrauf addieren von den Zahlen, äh weil eben weniger getestet wurde, sie Tests sind um fünfzehn Prozent zurückgegangen
und hätten wir genauso viel getestet oder das Testregime nicht geändert kann man sagen wahrscheinlich fünf bis zehn Prozent mehr, was halt bedeutet, dass die Zahlen nicht wirklich sinken, sondern wir immer noch knapp,
über eins sind. Also es hat sich da eigentlich beim RWT nur ein bisschen was äh getan äh und das.
Hängt auch ein ein Stück weit mit dem veränderten Testregime zusammen.
Das veränderte Testregime ist, dass man jetzt eigentlich sagt, wir wollen jetzt nur noch Leute mit Symptomen testen.
Oder zumindest bevorzugt, ich weiß nicht so ganz genau wie das jetzt konkret durchgezogen wird, gab da auch viel Diskussion dadrüber so ah wenn ich jetzt keine Symptome habe aber meine Corona Warnap sagt rot was ist dann, ne?
Hab ich jetzt keine belastbaren Informationen bekommen so wie es meine rausgehört zu haben ist das aber immer noch gilt.
Dass man mit so einer äh roten App dann entsprechend,
auch 'n Test bezahlt bekommen, man kann natürlich immer noch auf eigene Kostentests machen, klar, diese Option gibt's natürlich immer noch.
Aber ähm na ja, das ist äh natürlich insofern beunruhigend. Ich würde sagen, wir gehen einfach mal davon aus, dass wir so ein R von ungefähr eins Komma eins haben.
Das bedeutet schlicht, dass die dass die Infektionen noch zunehmen.
Wahrscheinlich eher so eins Komma null fünf, würde ich sagen, also ist wirklich nur ganz knapp
über eins äh mal wie gesagt, aber durch wir werden's halt sehen, wenn sich das jetzt äh stabilisiert äh weiter mit den Tests, also in einer Woche ungefähr können wir das äh sehen und,
dann kann man auch sehen, ob's noch weiter runter geht dann oder wieder hoch geht oder sich stabilisiert. Was man.
Aber äh definitiv sehen kann ist äh dass wir jetzt ähm.
Aktivität oder oder Hotspots.
Überall haben oder oder in den meisten Ländern, also in äh zehn Ländern, also zehn Länder sind in der Top dreißig Risikoliste vertreten, die ich äh da immer rechne, auf Pabelmaier DEDRISG.
Also Bundesländer.
Ja genau, also Landkreise aus zehn verschiedenen Bundesländern sind im Moment in den Top dreißig so
Normalerweise waren's eher so fünf, sechs und es gab immer einen deutlichen Spitzenreiter, so Bayern hat halt oft
Jahr zehn, ich glaube sogar mal zwölf von äh ich glaube mal siebzehn von dreißig Landkreisen oder so in den Top dreißig waren bayerische Landkreise. Im Moment sind's nur sieben
vier in Thüringen, vier in NRW, vielen Sachsen, drei in Berlin, zwei in Hessen, zwei in Rheinland-Pfalz, zwei in Baden-Württemberg, einen in Brandenburg und einen in Niedersachsen, also man sieht schon,
ja es ist überall Kovit ist überall fast überall.
Ja und äh auch interessant unser äh altbekannter Landkreis Sonneberg, der vor Monaten.
Da immer mal wieder äh so in der Spitzengruppe war, von dem man lange nichts mehr gehört hat, der ist jetzt wieder ganz oben. So, da äh,
ist 'n neuer Ausbruch und ansonsten Cottbus hält sich weiter an der Spitze und,
ja, dann haben wir gleich zwei mit Kaufbäuren und Passau und Augsburg gleich drei bayerische Landkreise noch ganz.
Ähm ja und im direkten Ländervergleich ist
Berlin in der Risikoliste, also
das Risikoranking vielleicht mal dazu sagen ist so eine Kombination aus Inzidenz und wie die sich verändert hat und wird sozusagen linear fortgeschrieben. Also wenn sich jetzt von der.
Von.
Es in den letzten sieben Tagen gegenüber den sieben Tagen davor verdoppelt hat, geht der Risikowert davon aus, dass es sich
in sieben Tagen nochmal verdoppelt und nimmt das halt für das für das Ranking manchmal als Erklärung, weil das jetzt lange nicht mehr erklärt äh äh hatten und,
da ist halt im Ranking.
Berlin leider noch ganz oben, auch wenn's jetzt nicht das äh äh höchste Wachstum hat und auch
in Berlin, gerade bei eins Komma null drei ist so ja und,
Allerdings sind die Zahlen in zwölf Bundesländern rückläufig
allerdings nicht so stark rückläufig, dass sie wirklich rückläufig wären, wenn man eben das Testregime äh mit einbezieht, vielleicht
Bremen äh so äh mit,
R von null Komma neun vier, aber selbst das ist äh ja, ja, eher fraglich. Also ich würde sagen, es sieht so aus, als würden die Zahlen zurückgehen, aber.
Nicht wirklich so im Grund.
In einem Maße, dass man jetzt sagen kann, oh
dann können wir ja die Maßnahmen auch schnell wieder äh zurücknehmen, weil jetzt ist ja wieder alles gut. Dazu müssten wir eigentlich mal für ein oder zwei Wochen wirklich signifikant mit einem wirklich belastbaren Ehrwert
unter eins liegen.
Und zwar deutlich, aber da kommen wir
was wirklich Tolles gefunden, was ich schon wirklich sehr lange äh haben wollte, also eine Studie, aber da kommen noch später zu, nämlich äh wie sich denn verschiedene Maßnahmen jetzt eigentlich auf,
R auswirken.
Vielleicht nochmal kurze Anmerkung aus der Tabelle äh heraus. Ich habe gerade mal wieder so äh anders sortiert. Das geht ja bei deiner Tabelle mal so toll, um mal so ein paar andere Gesichtspunkte rauszuholen. Ich hab's jetzt mal so nach den Todesfällen,
je hunderttausend, also wie stark sind sozusagen die einzelnen Landkreise jetzt wirklich von Todesfällen betroffen gewesen
Also da hatten wir ja schon hier unseren Dauer äh Brenner, ist ja der Landkreis äh Tirschenreuth, der überstrahlt nach wie vor äh alles mit äh gut zweihundert,
Toten äh auf auf hunderttausend.
Also zwei Prozent sozusagen der Bürger dieses Landkreises.
Null Komma zwei müssten's eigentlich sein oder enttäusche ich mich da.
Zweihundert null ja null Komma zwei Entschuldigung, null Komma zwei selbstverständlich. Ähm.
Da ist schon der nächste bei der Hälfte, aber wenn man sich da so mal die ersten dreißig anschaut.
Bayern, Bayern, Bayern, Bayern, Bayern, bisschen Baden-Württemberg bisschen Nordrhein-Westfalen, bis in Thüringen, äh aber im Wesentlichen Bayern.
Okay, also ich sag zusammengefasst kann man sagen äh jetzt deutschlandweites.
Ihr Größenordnung eins Komma null fünf wirklich und nicht null Komma neun neun und
ein positives hat aber der Rückgang der Tests, nämlich das jetzt der Probenrückstau sich wieder reduziert hat und das ist jetzt wieder äh ungefähr wie vor einem Monat äh etwa
das so pro Tag zwanzigtausend
Proben liegen bleiben während das halt zwischendurch mal hunderttausend war, wobei es in Wirklichkeit auch ein bisschen mehr sind, weil nicht alle Labore unbedingt in Probenrückstau immer melden. Also da kann man wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen was
äh oben drauf packen, aber was sich auch lohnt, ab und zu mal einen Blick reinzuwerfen, ähm.
Jetzt äh oder seit einiger Zeit schon ausführliche Wochenberichte zur Testung, die auch immer umfangreicher.
Geworden sind und äh da.
Sind halt verschiedene Auswertungen zum Beispiel wie viele Altersgruppen getestet wurden und
wo getestet wird und da findet man zum Beispiel interessanten Fakt, dass die meisten Leute sich in Arztpraxen nach wie vor testen,
lassen so äh als Alternative gibt's noch Krankenhaus und andere äh.
Und interessanterweise sind aber auch bei den Ärzten,
die Anzahl der positiven Tests höher als bei den Tests in den Kategorien Krankenhaus und andere. Wahrscheinlich sind andere
Altersheime oder Einreiseteststellen, wo halt Verdachtsunabhängig getestet wird
ebenso in den Krankenhäusern kann ich mir vorstellen, wird eine Menge wird mehr verdachtsunabhängig getestet werden. Wenn die Leute zum Arzt gehen und sich testen lassen, sie wahrscheinlich dann schon.
Werden ja alle alle Patienten, die stationär aufgenommen werden getestet.
Ist es so jetzt mittlerweile.
Hatte da gerade etwas Einblick ähm wenn man da äh reinkommt und es ist klar, dass man stationär aufgenommen werden muss, also jetzt nicht wegen äh Corona, sondern aus irgendwelchen anderen Gründen
Unfall, was weiß ich, Operationen, sonstige Probleme, die man haben kann. Das gibt's ja auch noch. Ähm dann
ich kenne das jetzt zumindest aus einer aus einer Kinderklinik ähm dann
werden in der ersten, am ersten Tag oder erste Nacht äh die Person sozusagen in Einzelzimmer gepackt,
bis dann der Test äh durch ist und danach werden dann halt äh die Leute wieder zusammengelegt, wie man das kennt.
Also das ist jetzt eine anekdotische Evidenz. Ja, das kann äh,
auch sein, dass das woanders anders ist, aber ich meine, ist ja vollkommen klar, die wollen natürlich sich da jetzt niemanden ins Krankenhaus äh reinholen, der da alle
das ganze Personal mit ansteckt, deswegen erscheint mir das ganz nachvollziehbar zu sein, was du sagst, dass es halt Praxen ist, weil da gehen die Leute hin, wenn sie wirklich Verdacht haben, wenn sie wirklich ein Problem
und vor allem nur können sie dort auch eigentlich nur also die Erwartungshaltung ist wahrscheinlich dort auch da kriege ich auch nur einen Test, wenn ich jetzt wirklich Symptome habe.
Ja ähm na was dann ansonsten auch noch äh drin war, was ich ähm.
Auch äh immer schon mal wissen wollte, wie,
verteilen sich denn die Tests auf die Bundesländer und auf die Altersgruppen. So, beim Bundesländern kann man sagen,
Es ist unauffällig eher, also also da ist mir ist mir jetzt nichts aufgefallen, aber bei dem.
Verlauf nach Altersgruppen.
Wie gut durchgetestet äh oder wie viel durchgetestet werden, eigentlich die Altersgruppen. Da gibt es
doch Unterschiede äh vom ja bis zu zweieinhalbfachen, also manche Altersgruppen, äh da werden deutlich mehr getestet und interessanterweise sind es,
Altersgruppen fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig und die über Achtzigjährigen, die hal,
fast doppelt so oft getestet werden wie die Altersgruppen aus welchen Gründen auch immer,
was sich da aber jetzt durch die Änderung ergeben hat bei dem Testregime ist jetzt vorher waren die fünfzehn bis vierunddreißigjährigen,
im alten Testregime an der Spitze und jetzt sind die über Achtzigjährigen, die die am meisten getestet werden, allerdings,
ist da auch die Testrate zurückgegangen, also von vorher ungefähr auf.
Achthundertfünfzig, ne achthundertneunzig neun knapp neunhundert, nicht ganz neunhundert pro hunderttausend über achtzigjährige
ja, dass es halt jetzt also von neunhundert auf achthundert ungefähr achthundertneunzig auf neun,
Ja? Also das Interessante ist erstmal.
Das ist die positiven Rate. Die ist interessanterweise in fast allen Altersgruppen außer den null bis Vierjährigen äh läuft die.
Seltsamerweise überall gleich, was.
Ich sag mal für die Qualität des Testregimes sprechen könnte, weil man sagen kann okay irgendwie scheint es so.
Austariert zu sein, dass die positiven Quote in allen Altersgruppen ungefähr gleich ist, ja? Aber.
Die Anzahl der Tests, äh die in den Altersgruppen gemacht werden, die variieren und dadurch variiert dann natürlich auch die Inzidenz äh äh so,
bei den äh in den Altersgruppen. So, während komischerweise die positiven Rate relativ nah beieinander ist.
So vielleicht jetzt zum äh äh Testen äh zusammengefasst, kann man sagen. Ja, in manchen Altersgruppen wird halt bis zu zwei, zweieinhalb mal mehr getestet in null,
bis äh äh vier und fünf bis vierzehn wird wenig getestet und fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig und achtzig plus wird vier getestet so. Aber,
Grundsätzlich gilt halt stärker getestete Gruppen haben auch eine höhere Inzidenz.
Was sich der Minum darin auswirkt, dass die positiven Quote bei allen ungefähr gleich ist. Also schon bisschen äh äh seltsam.
Und ja allerdings testen wir eben auch
aktuell jetzt weniger alte. Ich hätte ja erwartet, dass die Änderungen im Testregime oder dass man da so verfährt, dass man sagt, okay, aber wir müssen die Alten unbedingt schützen, deswegen testen wir da jetzt
nicht weniger, aber im Endeffekt hat's dazu geführt, dass die alten auch weniger getestet werden. So, nicht gut.
Finde ich. Ja.
Weiß nicht, ob wir erst die Berliner Zahlen nehmen oder erst die Ergebnisse der Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am Montag.
Erstmal diese Zahl, da ist mal fertig.
Okay. Ähm ja Berlin verhält sich
grundsätzlich nicht sehr viel anders als der Bund, wobei wir äh in Berlin heute,
keinen Rekord hatten an Neuinfektionen und der sieben Tagesschnitt etwas stärker gesunken ist äh als im Bund
und äh sagen die Zahl der Toten nicht ganz so krass äh ansteigt, aber.
So R ist definitiv selbst mit.
Den rückläufigen Testzahlen immer noch in in Berlin definitiv über eins und jetzt im Moment deutlicher als im Bund, also eher so eins Komma eins eins Komma zwei, also,
Berlin steigt noch deutlich und wenn man jetzt noch äh einbezieht, dass weniger getestet wird, kann man sagen ja sind wahrscheinlich eher eins Komma zwei fünf oder so, also in Berlin,
ist noch nicht ist nichts mit Ruhe, so ist also.
Berlin wird noch gefeiert.
In Berlin wird noch gefeiert, beziehungsweise geshoppt halt, was man so gesehen hat, äh dass die Leute halt jetzt stat,
eben ins Restaurant, gehen sie dann halt in die Shopping-Mall und trinken da einen Kaffee und treffen sich jetzt in der Shopping-Mall mit anderen Leuten ähm ja.
Also nicht so richtig toll und.
Berlin habe ich fallen mir auch immer die Institzen
raus, da ist leider auch bei den Achtzigjährigen jetzt wieder einen deutlichen Anstieg nachdem so aussah, dass Ausbrüche in Altersheim
Unter Kontrolle wären, ist nicht so neuen Ausbrüchen gekommen in der Altersgruppe und die steigt jetzt wieder am stärksten äh mit,
Wir in allen anderen Altersgruppen zumindest bei den Zahlen.
Leichten Institzrückgang haben, aber der teilweise auch noch Testregime äh getrieben sein kann.
Ja und bei den Bezirken ja Neukölln und,
Mitte immer noch mit äh abenteuerlichen Institzen. Ach ja und vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, hatten wir eigentlich beim letzten Mal schon
über meine neuen Spalten geredet, die ich eingebaut hatte in die Tabelle. Ich glaube nicht. Ja, das habe ich erst danach gemach.
Jedoch, das hattest du schon erwähnt. Ja, ja.
Okay, ja, ich habe jetzt äh hatte für die, die es nicht mitbekommen haben, jetzt auch eingebaut. Ähm vier Spalten, wo die Felle.
Oder die Inzidenzen berechnet werden, so wie das RKI sie berechnet.
Nämlich alles, was länger als sieben Tage braucht, fällt unterm Tisch und habe äh dort jetzt die Quote auch, wie viel beim RKI unter den Tisch fällt.
Und das ist weniger geworden. So, kann man sagen, was.
Daran liegt, dass jetzt das Testen nicht mehr ganz so lange dauert. Also das sieht man da jetzt auch ganz gut,
und ansonsten der Rest nimmt sich dann nicht viel. Ja, Pankow, Lichtenberg, also die Ostbezirke,
halb so schlimm wie äh Neukölln und Mitte aber immer noch schlimm genug. So.
Ja gut, ist derzeit nirgendswo so richtig.
Mein an der Stelle vielleicht kann man auch sagen äh einmal versprochen Blick, wir machen auch noch einen Blick ins Intensivregister
und da auch da steht Berlin am schlimmsten da. Einmal also jetzt,
Ja, jedenfalls im Ländervergleich mit fast fünfundzwanzig Prozent Belegung der Intensivbetten durch Kurvit-Patienten
es gibt zwar ein paar Landkreise sowie Oberspreewald Lausitz, da sind über fünfzig Prozent der Intensivbetten mit Kowit-Patienten belegt, aber dieser Landkreis hat nur neun Intensivbetten, also insofern
ja, äh, kann man das jetzt nicht vergleichen, aber generell kann man sagen, sind fast überall noch Betten frei.
Das heißt, du kannst in dem Intensiv äh Register für jeden Landkreis sehen, wie viel Intensivkapazität es da überhaupt gibt. Ah, das war ja fast aber in der Tabelle aufnehmen.
Ja. Also ähm und äh was sie auch jetzt äh äh.
Drin haben oder auch schon seit längerem sind halt die.
Zeit rein, so wie sich das Ganze denn entwickelt und.
Entwickelt sich nicht gut. Also die Zahl der intensivmedizinisch behandelten Kowit Fälle äh steigt,
deutschlandweit noch exponentiell an und ist jetzt mit weit über also dreitausen,
siebenhundert oder so höher als in der ersten Welle
In Berlin sogar fast doppelt so hoch wie in der ersten Welle mit ja über dreihundert Patienten, die gerade intensiv medizinisch behandelt werden,
und man kann auch sehen, dass die Zahl der freien äh äh Betten.
Stetig zurückgeht, äh, wobei die sogenannte Notfallreserve noch unangetastet äh ist.
So. Ja.
Also was es mit Notfallreserve gemeint, das sind diese ganzen Notfall äh Krankenhäuser, wie jetzt hier in Berlin, in der Messehalle und sowas oder wie. Oh.
Ähm ja, das sind man eigentlich.
Die jetzt nicht regulär betrieben werden, sondern wo man dann äh andere Ärzte, die eigentlich.
Zu deren Job das normalerweise nicht gehört dann oder andere Pfleger dann halt dorthin äh versetzt äh werden, um dann sich äh äh darum zu kümmern.
Nehme ich an äh so,
äh dass das dass das in der Praxis äh so läuft mit dieser Notfalllreserve, weil da gibt's halt eigentlich niemanden regulär,
also kein reguläres Personal für, deswegen wird man dann für die Notfalllreserve, wenn sie in Anspruch genommen wird, irgendwelche Ärzte.
Und Pfleger aus ganz anderen, von ganz anderen Stationen.
Bisschen merkwürdig, wenn ihr mir diese Grafik anschaue hier mit den äh gemeldeten Intensivbetten, dass die halt seit August.
Zurückgeht. Also also sozusagen ins.
Insgesamt äh ich weiß nicht, hier ist keine keine Summe direkt in Zahlen angegeben, aber wir waren hier,
schon mal so auf dem Weg zu fünfundvierzigtausend inklusive dieser Not äh Fallreserve, selbst wenn man die Notfallreserve weglässt, ist sozusagen die Zahl der verfügbaren Betten geht zurück.
Ja. Wenn ich mir nicht so richtig erklären warum. Paar hundert.
Wahrscheinlich wurde dann erst eingeführt, dass die Notfallreserve gemeldet,
wird. Es gab vorher, also vor vor August gab's irgendwie diese Notfalllreservestatistik nicht, deswegen nehme ich an, aber in der Tat, gehen sie etwas zurück, aber ja,
Vielleicht nehmen Leute jetzt auch Urlaub oder sind in Quarantäne oder ähm erkrankt oder.
Also es ist sozusagen eher am Personal liegt als an den tatsächlichen Betten, ja. Okay.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Davon äh gehe ich mal aus. Also, ich gehe mal aus, dass es um betreibbare Betten äh äh geht.
Da ist eh die Frage, inwiefern die Notfallreserve dann auch wirklich das hält, was sie verspricht, sollten wir sie denn nochmal.
Gebrauchen. So oder so ähm diese Woche gab's einen neuen Gipfel.
Da haben sich also die Politikerinnen und Politiker wieder zusammengefunden, vor allem halt die Kanzlerin und all die ganzen Länder Chefs und Chefinnen, ich weiß gar nicht, wie es gerade
Frauenquote bei Ministerpräsidentinnen, also gar nicht besonders hoch auf nicht hoch genug. Nicht ausreichend hoch. Ähm am sechzehnten.
November, also vor vier Tagen.
Am Montag.
Irgendwie irgendwie ist nichts passiert.
Ja, keine Verschärfungen. Also das Ergebnis ist Appell an alle Bürger, die Kontakte doch zu minimieren, auf private Feiern zu verzichten und Kontakte auf einen festen Hausstand zu
begrenzen, was auch immer das heißen mag. Ist das jetzt auf dem Hausstand oder äh was ist jetzt mit festen Hausstand,
gemeint, gibt's auch ein variablen Hausstand oder nicht festen Hausstand oder,
soll man sich jetzt gar nicht mehr mit Freunden treffen, äh vermute mal, das ist gemeint. Keine Treffen mit gar keinem.
Aber Appell.
Wenn man appelliert, also man will das irgendwie, aber man traut sich nicht, dass du so so richtig vorzuschreiben.
Und das geht so ein bisschen davon aus, dass das schon irgendwie äh es genug Leute gibt, die da mitmachen. Aber ich habe so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, dass es stattfindet, weil dann würden unsere Zahlen noch spürbarer zurückgehen.
Und die Kanzlerin hat wohl angekündigt, dass ein längerfristiges Konzept geplant ist, was halt bis ins neue Jahr gelten soll und das soll dann nächsten Mittwoch, am fünfundzwanzigsten November,
bekannt gegeben werden. Das war auch ein Ergebnis. Also da ist noch was ähm Söder wird zitiert mit, es reicht noch nicht,
ähm so und da muss ich ihm dann mal nicht sagen, ausnahmsweise aber mal Recht geben. Es reicht nicht,
und ich würde sogar sagen.
Eigentlich ist es ein Skandal, was da am Montag passiert ist. Weil es ist mittlerweile absehbar, dass die Maßnahmen nicht ausreichen. Guten Montag war es vielleicht noch ein bisschen,
weniger absehbar.
Aber es war auch schon am Montag absehbar. Und jetzt ist es endgültig absehbar, dass Verschärfungen unausweichlich sind und.
Es kommt zu spät äh einfach, ja. Was die Ministerpräsidenten faktisch am Montag gemacht haben bedeutet ja, ein Todesurteil für Tausende vor allem älterer Menschen.
Die halt jetzt äh sterben werden, weil nicht gehandelt wurde und die ziemlich sicher nicht gestorben wäre, wenn man gehandelt hätte und noch,
weniger.
Menschen werden gestorben, wenn man halt vor vier Wochen oder vor acht Wochen geplant hätte und am Montag wurden jetzt hunderttausende zusätzlicher Infektionen in Kauf genommen. Ja, muss man
auch sagen, so wenn man das allein in Kosten macht so ein Kobit-Fall kostet, äh, man vielleicht fürs nächste Mal mal berechnen, was kostet denn
wirtschaftlich so ein infizierter uns eigentlich, was das äh für ein äh wirtschaftlicher Schaden ist. Es ist ähm.
Sagen denn echter Skandal. Und in dem Zusammenhang äh wird's vielleicht auch nochmal Sinn machen, warum,
es sich um den Skandal äh handelt, äh weil es eigentlich mittlerweile bekannt ist in etwa,
wie sich so typische Maßnahmen auswirken,
Und ich habe da eine recht interessante Studie gefunden aus dem Landset, also ein renommiertes Magazin und,
in dieser Studie wurde
ich glaube hundertzweiunddreißig Länder wurden angeschaut, welche Maßnahmen hat man dort wann getroffen und,
Wie hat sich dann daraufhin die Infektionen entwickelt und hat dann mit bestimmten mathematischen Methoden äh versucht, rauszurechnen, wie sich denn,
die Maßnahmen ausgewirkt haben und zwar über die.
Ersten achtundzwanzig Tage, nachdem so eine Maßnahme eingeführt wurde.
Und das Ergebnis ist wirklich sehr interessant, nicht alles ist überraschend, aber es gibt äh schon so ein paar.
Überraschungen. Vielleicht ja macht es mal Sinn, die einzelnen Maßnahmen äh mal zumindest anzusprechen und,
zu quantifizieren oder zu sehen, auf was die denn da dort gekommen sind in der in der Studie und wir haben also sowohl versucht,
die Wirkung einzelner Maßnahmen rauszurechnen als auch dann Maßnahmen in Kombination, was wie viel bringt es, wenn man sagen die Maßnahme draufsattelt auf,
andere Maßnahmen, wie viel geht es dann zurück? Und das Ergebnis ist so in.
Einem Prozentsatz oder einem Verhältnis, um wie viel äh R.
Vergrößert oder verkleinert wurde durch eine entsprechende Maßnahme und zwar in Prozent.
Und da kann man äh definitiv sagen, öffentliche Veranstaltungen ähm also Großveranstaltungen haben,
die größte Wirkung.
Ach so und es wurde geguckt, okay, um wie viel gehen die Zahlen runter, wenn eine Maßnahme eingeführt wird und um wie viel gehen die Zahlen rauf, wenn eine Maßnahme abgeschafft wird, weil das,
ist nämlich interessanterweise auch nicht identisch. So ist es nicht so, dass eine eine Einführung einer Maßnahme und eine Abschaffung einer Maßnahme wirken sich nicht symmetrisch aus,
so dass es vielleicht auch eine wichtige Erkenntnis und öffentliche Veranstaltungen verbieten,
kann so im Schnitt den RWT auf fünfundsiebzig Prozent ungefähr sechsundsiebzig Prozent als einzelne Maßnahmen senken gegenüber, wenn man gar nichts macht.
Das heißt halt äh wenn ich vorher einen R von eins Komma fünf habe, so und,
ich hab jetzt fünfundsiebzig Prozent so, dann lande ich bei 'nem R von eins Komma eins zwei fünf.
Ja. So, nur durch.
Großveranstaltungen äh äh verbieten. Aber nicht unbedingt in allen Fällen, also sie haben dort auch eine eine Fehler angegeben und das Interessante ist, wenn ich dann öffentliche Veranstaltungen wieder zulasse, so,
steigt es nicht ganz so stark an am äh Ende der achtundzwanzig Tage so habe ich.
Sagen, dass dann das eins Komma zwei eins Fache äh wieder anere. So, also fast wieder da, wo ich vorher war.
Das heißt.
Klar, wenn die Veranstaltung abgesagt haben, werden dann nimmt erstmal keiner dran teil. So, das ist mehr oder weniger ja für alle dann sofort der Effekt, aber in dem Moment, wo sie dann wieder stattfinden, heißt es ja nicht, dass auch alle, die vorher hingegangen werden, auch sofort dahin rennen.
So kann man das glaube ich lesen, ne?
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall ist es aber ungefähr symmetrisch. Äh so als zwei.
Stärkste Maßnahme äh wirkt sich und das Schließen von,
Schulen aus. Ungefähr nach Schulschließung, so achtundzwanzig Tage später äh ist der Wert auf fünfundachtzig Prozent.
Aber das Öffnen von Schulen äh vergrößert interessanterweise
um vierundzwanzig Prozent, also deutlich größere Asymmetrie, also Schulen schließen bringt nicht ganz so viel wie Schulen öffnen, ja achtundzwanzig Tage später an äh.
Übertragungen an mehr.
Nachvollziehbar, ne? Also ist die Schule dicht, gehen natürlich die Schüler nicht mehr hin, äh ist die Schule wieder da, gehen natürlich alle Schüler wieder hin und zwar alle,
ja? Und äh dann natürlich gleich mit dieser Erwartung, es wäre jetzt alles besser als vorher und man müsste sich ja vielleicht jetzt nicht mehr so sehr einschränken.
Und die drittstärkste Auswirkung hat interessanterweise das Schließen von Firmen, also Arbeitsplätze.
Natürlich nicht nicht alle, aber wenn man sagt, sagen wir machen alle Firmen dicht im Prinzip, die nicht kriegsentscheidend äh sind, dann schafft man immerhin minus dreizehn Prozentpunkte.
Öffnet man dann aber wieder, hat man so gut wie keine zusätzlichen,
Infektion hinterher, so. Zu mit anderen Worten zu machen, bringt was und das bleibt dann aber beim äh Wiedereröffn.
Die bleiben alle im Home Office sitzen sozusagen. Feuer.
Bleiben entweder im Homeoffice oder hat dann
die Sachen sicher gemacht, was man vielleicht noch sagen muss, die Studie basiert auf Zahlen bis einschließlich Juli. Also wir haben jetzt da die ist die zweite Welle, ist da jetzt noch nicht mit,
drin.
Ja, insofern haben wir da auch Effekte oder Lerneffekte äh mit drin, zwangsläufig in der Studie, äh die halt aufgetreten sind, ähm quasi.
Beim ersten Mal, was ist dann passiert, nachdem die Leute dann durch den Schließungsschock äh oder durch den Lokdown gegangen sind und wie viel unvorsichtiger sind sie geworden.
Dann als weitere Maßnahme grenzschließung. Grenzschließung.
Ist total interessant, weil kurzfristig minus elf Prozentpunkte.
Haben die gebracht, aber langfristig äh komplett wirkungslos beziehungsweise kontraproduktiv.
Und äh interessanterweise sozusagen nach Aufhebungen der Grenzschließungen hat man zumindest geringfügig niedrigere Zahlen als äh sagen. Was.
Mir nicht ganz eck oder ich kann's mir nur nur so erklären, dass ähm wenn man die Grenzen dicht gemacht hat.
Dass die Leute dann einfach äh nach einer Weile, äh weil sie denn dann unbedingt mussten, dann mehr oder weniger illegal.
Eingereist sind und sich dann auch nicht an Quarantäne gehalten haben und möglicherweise erstmal die Grenzen dann wieder aufgemacht hat. Ähm.
Dass äh dann durch Tests und andere äh Dinge äh sogar die Zahlen runtergegangen sind. Das ist jetzt nicht das, was wir unbedingt in Deutschland.
Sehen konnten oder gesehen haben mit dem wie wir das mit den Reiseregimen gemacht haben, aber interessanterweise bei Grenzschließung in der Praxis sind komische Dinge passiert, statistisch gesehen.
Auf welche Länder äh hat's äh Lenz Studie jetzt geschaut? Also weltweit oder war das eine eine bestimmte Liste? Weltweit, okay.
Weltweit. Also das ist eine Länderliste drin, wie gesagt, hundertdreißig Länder weltweit.
Aber das ist doch super Pavel, dann haben wir doch die Lösung. Wir müssen einfach immer nur alle Grenzen schließen, kurzfristig, dann wieder aufmachen.
Und dann wieder schließen und dann wieder aufmachen und dann gehen die Zahlen immer weiter runter.
Ich meine, das wäre dann die nächste Studie, wie wie sieht es beim zweiten Mal aus? Da wird's bestimmt eine nach eine Folgestudie geben in einem halben Jahr, okay? Wie ist es denn bei der zweiten Welle äh gelaufen, wie hat sich das denn da? Zeitlich entwickelt.
Okay, was.
Auch rausgefunden hat, ÖPNV bringt nicht viel, bringt ein bisschen, bringt irgendwie ein Prozentpunkt weniger.
Beim Dichtmachen und vier Prozentpunkte mehr beim Öffnen. So ÖPNV scheint nicht so,
der Kracher zu sein, das deckt sich wohl auch mit anderen Studien, die das jetzt zwar nicht zeitlichen Verlauf, sondern sagen nur versucht haben, das zu quantifizieren, das scheint nicht viel zu bringen
treffen, größer zehn Leute verbieten,
Also Kontaktbeschränkungen haben auch nicht viel gebracht. Vermutlich, weil die Leute sich nicht dran gehalten haben oder.
Weil nicht jedenfalls drei minus drei Prozentpunkte.
Wenn man sie einführt während nachdem man sie dann abgeschafft hat, die Kontaktbeschränkungen ist das halt um fünfundzwanzig Prozentpunkte nach oben,
gegangen, der RW hat. Also, genau der umgekehrte Effe.
Die man eigentlich haben möchte, weil wahrscheinlich die Leute dann dir dieses Signal bekommen. Es ist jetzt okay, sich zu treffen und dann treffen sich gleich richtig.
Denken, ah okay äh jetzt kann ich mich wieder mit Leuten treffen und treffen sich dann vielleicht sogar mehr als sie sich getroffen hätten vor der Maßnahme ist die Maßnahme dann quasi nochmal so ein bisschen Sehnsucht äh erzeugt.
Und dazu führt, dass im Endeffekt mehr Treffen stattfinden als Voreinführung der Maßnahmen. Was ist jetzt langfristig bedeutet
muss man sehen, aber auf jeden Fall in dem Moment, wo man den Leuten erlaubt, sich wieder zu treffen, gibt das den absolut höchsten Boost auf den RW,
Laut dieser Studie ähnlich mit Ausgangsbeschränkungen, die bringen auch
drei Prozentpunkte aber hebt man sie wieder auf. Elf Prozentpunkte nach oben. Und bei Reisebeschränkungen im Land minus sieben Prozentpunkte und bei Aufheben dreizehn Prozentpunkte,
mehr. Das waren jetzt die Einzelmaßnahmen. So. Wenn wir jetzt nochmal einen Blick auf.
Kombination von Maßnahmen gucken, wenn wir jetzt,
Verbot öffentlicher Veranstaltung und maximal zehn Leute dürfen sich treffen dann haben wir dreißig Prozentpunkte Reduktion.
Die Einzelmaßnahmen, wenn man die sich jetzt anguckt wären.
Vierundzwanzig Prozentpunkte und drei, also siebenundzwanzig, also anderen Worten, so wenn man zwei Maßnahmen kombiniert, dann ist es mehr, als wenn man jetzt einfach nur die Prozentpunkte
addiert. So, das kann man hier schon mal feststellen. Äh macht man jetzt noch die Firmen zu, also
Homeoffice, sage ich mal, äh äh
kommt man auf zweiundsechzig Prozent der ursprünglichen hundert Prozent, also wenn man eher auch mit hundert Prozent angefangen hat, nimmt man auch Ausgangsbeschränkungen dazu, weitere äh vier Prozent,
auf achtundfünfzig Prozent und Schulschließung, die bringen halt minus fünfzehn Prozentpunkte und plus vierundzwanzig Prozentpunkte,
Das heißt, mit der gesamten Maßnahmenpalette hier kommt man auf achtundvierzig Prozent ungefähr runter.
Also Veranstaltungen, die ich äh weniger als Leute zehn Leute treffen, Homeoffice, Ausgangsbeschränkungen irgendeiner, das ist jetzt die Frage, was genau für Ausgangsbeschränkungen sollen das sein? Also, dass man irgendwie gar nicht mehr rausgehen darf oder was, oder,
Na gut, ich meine, da machen ja auch Schulschließungen keinen Sinn mehr, wenn man nicht mehr rausgehen darf, dann ist ja eh alles vorbei. Also.
Na ja, Ausgangsbeschränkungen äh ist dann auch so nur zu bestimmten Zeiten oder nur zu bestimmten Zwecken. Also ist jetzt kein Ab also schon aber,
in Frankreich zum Beispiel hatten oder in Spanien
das zu nutzen oder in Tschechien auch, dass nur zu bestimmten Zeiten raus darfst und nicht nur im,
von zu Hause bewegen kannst, dass es nicht um ein Kilo nicht weiter als ein Kilometer von zu Hause weg darfst und dann,
von oder zur Arbeit gehen, falls.
Dringend arbeiten musst und ja also das gehe ich mal von aus.
Welche Maßnahmen haben wir denn in Deutschland gerade?
Ja, also eigentlich haben wir nur äh öffentliche Veranstaltungen und äh maximal zehn Leute treffen.
Homeoffice findet aber auch eine Menge statt.
Ja, ja, aber sozusagen, oh Homeoffice ist jetzt nicht staatlich verordnet.
Ne, das stimmt.
Gut, wir hatten aber dann außerdem so gewisse Maßnahmen ja vorher schon. Das war ja nicht nicht so, dass alles komplett freigegeben war. Also wir hatten sagen schon öffentliche Veranstaltungen waren,
eingeschränkt so, wir hatten überall diverse Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
und wenn man jetzt vergleicht, okay, was haben denn jetzt die Novembermaßnahmen eigentlich gebracht.
Dann haben wir den sieben Tage Erbe bislang von eins Komma drei fünf auf eins gesenkt. Also fünfundsiebzig Prozent vom,
vor Wert. Das ist da wo wir sind,
so also äh im Grunde genommen.
Schlechter als jede Maßnahmenkombination, Kombination von zwei Maßnahmen. Und und da kann man jetzt sagen, okay, da wird sich jetzt nicht mehr viel tun,
Ohne neue Maßnahmen kommen wir nicht weiter runter und wir sind definitiv über eins. So, also ähm.
Ja, es kann so nicht weitergehen. Selbst bei so auch bei der Zahl, wie viel Leute im Moment erkranken und äh können wir das nicht ewig durchhalten, so,
Insofern, ja, werden Maßnahmen kommen. Und wenn man sich jetzt anguckt, okay,
was können wir denn jetzt noch draufpacken? Dann sind es wesentlichen Ausgangsbeschränkungen und Schulen.
So. Ich sehe also Schulschließungen würden wohl am meisten bringen.
Homeoffice am zweitmeisten, also Prinzip.
Wieder alle Läden dicht machen außer Supermärkte äh und so und ähm ja.
Na ja, ich denke derzeit basiert ja einfach noch sehr viel auf macht das doppelt mal bitte. So,
Das ist ja,
nicht so, dass wir jetzt hier wirklich äh die Patrouille in der Straße haben, die das alles entforssen und die will ich auch nicht sehen, das ist äh nicht der Punkt. Trotz alledem ist klar und wir haben das ja eigentlich vor
Vor zwei Wochen auch schon
so gesagt, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, dass die, dass diese Maßnahmen, die wir jetzt ergreifen, also als es hieß ja hier der November und jetzt drehen wir mal auf die Bremse ab dem dritten November,
Mit den Zahlen, wie sie sich so gezeigt haben und mit den Maßnahmen, wie sie sich abgezeichnet haben, also mit dem Umfang dieser Maßnahmen war, glaube ich, nicht sehr viel mehr,
zu erwarten, als das was wir jetzt auch bekommen haben. Ja, es geht irgendwie so ein bisschen in so eine Stagnation.
Aber wir sehen auch, dass noch zu Zeiten dieser Stagnation die Problematik Leute werden sehr krank und sterben,
in Bereiche vorstößt, die schon nicht mehr schön sind, also zweihundert Leute pro Tag äh die sterben und was weiß ich, wie viele Leute davon noch Langzeitfolgen haben werden, wenn sie nicht daran sterben. Das, das will man alles nicht
haben, hat sogar noch ein bisschen Potenzial nach oben zu gehen. Also ich glaube, wir werden sicherlich noch zweihundertfünfzig pro Tag sterben sehen.
Das ist, das ist irgendwie, ja, es sind einfach tausende Leute, die äh daran sozusagen zugrunde gehen und das wird sich dann noch vier Wochen so halten.
Bis es irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise besser wird. Also die die Kurven, die jetzt die anderen Länder mit ihren starken Maßnahmen hinbekommen haben, das sind die Kurven, die wir jetzt eigentlich brauchen.
Sprich, wir können uns jetzt einreden, das ist irgendwie ein Weihnachten geben wird, aber eigentlich müsste man so bis Ende dieses Jahres mindestens diesen Modus beibehalten.
Oder was man sowieso schon hätte im September tun sollen, einfach mal einmal ganz kräftig wieder an der Handbremse ziehen und äh ja, das äh ganz unangenehme zu machen und das scheint aber derzeit politisch nicht durchsetzbar zu sein
Wofür ich auch ein gewisses Verständnis habe. Es gibt ja sehr viel Diskussionen um.
Die Schulen, jetzt hast du ja auch so hier rein nach den Zahlen und so, müssen wir mal die Schulen äh zu machen. Klar, ist wahrscheinlich auch so. Nur das Ding ist.
Die Schulen zu schließen glaube ich das ist somit das, was.
Am meisten super unangenehme Kollateralschäden mit sich bringt, weil das wirkt sich erstmal auf die Kinder aus natürlich.
Ja, abgesehen davon, dass die Schulen natürlich auch ähm.
Sozusagen drunter leiden, also sozusagen als äh System, weil es ist ja auch eine permanente Überforderung äh ist für das Personal, was was sich langfristig auswirken wird.
Aber in dem Moment, wo alle sich wieder um ihre Kinder äh selber zu Hause kümmern müssen und der Starter sozusagen, die eigentlich von ihm eingepflicht eingeforderte Schulpflicht nicht wahrnehmen kann. Das sorgt ja dann wiederum dafür, dass viele Leute dann einfach nicht.
Ihrer Arbeit nachgehen können, auch nicht zu Hause
mit den entsprechenden Betreuungsproblemen sozialen Problemen, psychischen Problemen, die sich das so äh mit sich bringt. Das haben natürlich auch Leute ohne Kinder, aber ich würde mal sagen, mit mit Kindern ist es einfach je nach Alter natürlich ähm nochmal
sehr viel schwieriger und ich kann von daher verstehen, dass man einen Maßnahmenkatalog haben will, wo,
Schulen offen bleiben oder zumindest die Schulen in einem Rahmen offen bleiben. Wir sehen ja jetzt auch schon Änderungen, also hier in Berlin, ich weiß nicht, das ist jetzt glaube ich ein gewisser Trend, aber in Berlin ist es jetzt ab nächster Woche äh vermutlich so, dass die Schulen, dass die Klassen geteilt werden.
Dass kleinere also sozusagen Hälfte Hälfte Gruppen gemacht werden einerseits und andererseits, dass eben auch die Anreise aufgeteilt wird, dass eben sozusagen nicht so ein großes Gedränge äh äh entsteht,
zum Beispiel im äh ÖPNV, auch wenn wir es gerade gehört haben, das bringt vielleicht jetzt nicht so, aber so total überfüllte
S-Bahnen sind auch normal kein keine Freude und es schafft einfach auch nur nochmal unnötigen psychischen Stress und dann wird es halt einfach äh anders gestreckt das Schulprogramm
und natürlich aber auch eingeschränkt dabei.
Ja und dann will man natürlich der Wirtschaft irgendwie nicht das Weihnachtsgeschäft komplett vermiesen und äh irgendwie läden dicht machen.
Ausgangsbeschränkung will auch niemand haben, ja? So es ist halt es gibt, dass das Ding ist, es gibt halt keine,
Maßnahmen mehr, die wir treffen können, die nicht wehtun. So, ja, das ist der Punkt und das Virus lässt sich halt nun mal.
Nicht beeindrucken durch irgendwie, da kann man irgendwie bitten und liebe Virus jetzt verschonen uns doch äh irgendwie, weil es ist halt äh so schlimm und äh.
Virus ist Weihnachten egal. Sagen wir es doch einfach.
Den Virus, es ist alles egal eigentlich äh so, dass ja.
Und insofern mein der Punkt ist.
Bei allem ja Verständnis äh so und aber wenn man das wirklich gewollt hätte.
Hätte man einfach,
andere Länder vor Monaten anders agieren müssen. Jetzt vielleicht sogar vor sechs Wochen noch in der Hand gehabt äh zu vermeiden,
ja? Äh vor sechs Wochen bevor äh die äh Gesundheitsämter die Kontrolle verloren haben.
Ja? Hätte man wahrscheinlich mit den Maßnahmen es noch geschafft unter null Komma neun äh unter eins zu kommen, ja. Aber weil zu spät gehandelt wurde,
So reichen die Maßnahmen jetzt nicht aus. Das ist einfach die Wahrheit und weil jetzt am Montag nicht gehandelt wurde
So reichen die Maßnahmen noch weniger nicht aus, so. Das heißt, das einzige, was durch dieses Verzögern
passiert ist, dass mehr Leute sterben, mehr Leute sich anstecken und wir am Ende härter Maßnahmen für einen längeren Zeitraum kriegen
So und das ist alles völlig klar
Das ist auch eigentlich den ganzen Experten äh klar und das müsste eigentlich auch den Ministerpräsidenten klar sein, ja,
So, aber äh ja ich weiß nicht. Ähm also das ist einfach mal.
Ja ich ich find's ein Skandal, ich find's ein Skandal. So.
Die Frage ist, was ist jetzt der Grund dafür, ne? Also ich meine, was jetzt äh im Rahmen dieser Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat äh glaube ich oder ich weiß nicht, ob das im Rahmen dieser Konferenz klar geworden ist oder was was zumindest mein Eindruck war, ist.
Die Kanzlerin hätte gerne mehr gemacht, aber so wie unsere Kräfteverteilung im.
In der Bundesrepublik ist, geht halt nichts mit den Ländern und die Länder.
Wollten sich quasi zu nichts verpflichten lassen. In der Summe, nicht dass ein einzelnes Land jetzt hier irgendwie Schuld wäre, keine Ahnung, wer da jetzt sich gegen was quer gestellt hat, aber es war einfach nicht möglich, sich bei,
sechzehn Beteiligten unter Gruppen in irgendeiner Form auf irgendwas zu äh einigen,
jeder nach Hause kommt und hört so ja, aber für uns sind die Maßnahmen ja gar nicht angemessen oder für uns sind sie ja uns, was weiß ich, betrifft es nicht oder.
Trifft diese Maßnahme härter als eine andere und das wollte keiner machen. Ne, wie wir das schon hatten, hier mit dem Michael Müller in Berlin, der dann halt auch irgendwie so die ganze Zeit so ja, hätte jetzt hier auch gerade noch irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, also auch diesen Brief im Briefkasten gehabt von ihm.
Weiß ich nicht.
Liebe Berlinerinnen und Berliner, so ein Din A4 äh Zettel, wo nochmal so äh um Verständnis
gebeten wird und bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte und da, ja, steht auch wieder drin, das ist, wie es schwer ist, ihm ja gefallen sei, all diese Einschränkungen zu beschließen und so weiter,
beschließt den Scheiß einfach, hätte der das im September gemacht,
Also was zum Beispiel war der gut im Nachhinein ist man immer schlauer, ne? Aber wir waren ja schon vorher schlauer. Von daher dürfen wir das sagen. Äh im Prinzip war klar,
Im September die Zahlen entwickeln sich nicht gut. Wir waren,
einfach auf einer Art Dreijektorie, die die absehbar in diese Richtung gezeigt hat, wo wir jetzt sind, weil alles über eins geht nicht.
Hätte man gesagt, okay Leute, in einer Woche machen wir für zwei Wochen dicht. Aber wir machen in zwei Wochen auf.
Und zwar garantiert und nicht nochmal treffen oder sonst irgendwie, sondern wir machen jetzt einfach mal nur genau diese zwei Wochen und wir halten jetzt mal richtig die Füße still und kauft euch nochmal genug Klubpapier in der nächsten Woche und.
So und dann weiß auch jeder, aha, es muss auch alles nur für zwei Wochen reichen, ja und dann kann man sogar, was weiß ich, Supermarktzeiten äh einschränken oder was weiß ich, keine Ahnung. Ich glau
ist am Ende nicht so das Problem gewesen. Richtig schön äh äh dicht und lockdown und la la übt schon mal für Weihnachten.
So und dann und dann wär's wahrscheinlich ausreichend abgebremst worden. Nicht null, aber ausreichend.
Na ja. Jetzt sind wir da.
Also hier hinten so noch ja siebenundzwanzigsten neunten, also so Ende September.
Sagen, hätte man handeln müssen, dann äh wäre uns das alles erspart geblieben.
Na ja. Gut so haben wir auf jeden Fall mehr äh Zeit ähm.
Wer Zeit? Für für andere Hobbys, ja, dann kann man wieder mehr.
Mhm.
Kuchen machen, kochen lernen und so weiter, ist halt so. Äh und wir haben äh auch mehr Zeit uns auf andere Heilsbringer zu konzentrieren.
Und vielleicht sollten wir jetzt mal kurz über die Entwicklung im Impfstoffbereich reden, denn da hat sich in der letzten Woche, nachdem ja Biontech,
mit dieser Meldung rausgekommen ist, dass sie jetzt hier einen erfolgreichen Impfstoff haben, hat sich ja einiges getan.
Und zwar hat die Firma Moderner,
aus den USA auch verkündet, dass sie einen Impfstoff am Start haben, dass ihre äh Studie mit dreißigtausend Teilnehmern.
Wohl sehr gut verlaufen ist.
Und dass sie von einer Wirksamkeit ihres Impfstoffs ausgehen von vierundneunzig Komma fünf Prozent zur Erinnerung, Björn Tech vor einer Woche mit neunzig Prozent.
Ähm dieser Impfstoff von moderner ist.
Im Prinzip dasselbe in grün, also auch hier ist auf diese brandneue sogenannte MRNA Technologie gesetzt worden, Messenger RNA
man schon länger so im Verdacht hatte, dass es da nochmal eine tolle Idee sein kann und jetzt im Prinzip erst ein Corona Viruszeiten.
War es halt einfach möglich, dass jetzt sehr, sehr, sehr schnell an Start zu bringen und sieht ganz so aus, als ob der Kram wirklich funktioniert. Ja, also es ist äh verträglich, wirksam, sehr wirksam, sehr viel wirksamer, als man das bei Impfstoffen normalerweise,
erwarten kann und.
So wie das eben technisch funktioniert, also das biochemische Prinzip, was hier zum Einsatz kommt, liegt auch nahe, dass eben Nebenwirkungen nicht so eine große Rolle spielen, weil hier werden keine.
Original Viren genommen und irgendwie verändert oder original Corona-Viren in abgetöteter Form gespritzt, was es ja bei anderen äh Krankheitsbekämpfungen alles schon mal gab.
Nein,
Hier wird einfach nur ein Baustein, ein Teil des Virus, ein ganz kleiner Teil ähm quasi nachgebaut in die Zellen geschickt und die sorgen dann dafür, dass eben nur ein einziger Teil, nämlich der ungefährliche Teil, ein einziges Protein.
Ähm des Virus nachgebaut wird und der Körper darauf schon reagieren kann, als wäre es das richtige Virus. Ne? Das ist äh im Prinzip die Story.
Der Impfschow von moderner ähm behauptet allerdings auch.
Sie nicht so eine extreme Kühlung brauchen, wie der von Biontech. Biontech sagt er, okay, äh,
besser bei minus siebzig Grad, also relativ niedrige Temperaturen
sonst kann's halt sein, dass der zerfällt und man hat noch nicht so ganz klare Erkenntnisse darüber, wie lange er danach hält, aber vielleicht so ein paar Tage bei niedrigeren Temperaturen, moderner behauptet, dass ihr Impfstoff,
schon bei minus zwanzig Grad dauerhaft gelagert werden kann. Fragt man sich natürlich, hm, okay, wenn das aber jetzt letztlich technisch genau dasselbe ist, was.
Was ist da jetzt der Deal? Soweit ich das verstanden habe, diese RNA ist ja quasi das, was in die Zelle gerät, aber du.
Hast in so einem Impfstoff jetzt nicht einfach so RNA rumfliegen, das die würde irgendwie nicht äh gar nichts überleben, sondern du musst die in irgendeiner Form einpacken und man packt die halt so ähnlich wie das Virus auch macht und solche Lipid äh Ketten.
Und so Fette und äh die sind dann halt unterschiedlich aufgebaut.
Und soweit ich das rausgelesen habe, ist es wohl moderner da gelungene, etwas stabilere äh Variante zu bauen, die eben dann nicht so sehr von höheren Temperaturen oder nicht ganz so niedrigen Temperaturen.
Betroffen ist. Das heißt
es könnte sehr gut sein, dass Ende dieses Jahres gleich zwei Unternehmen einen Impfstoff in das Rennen schicken
Und äh dass das in den USA jetzt auch so schnell gegangen ist äh ist tatsächlich auch mal auf die Unterstützung der US-Regierung zurückzuführen. Die haben da jetzt zwar nicht dran mitentwickelt und ähm
auch nicht direkt das finanziert, sonder,
Die haben da irgendwie so ein Programm aufgelegt, das hieß Operation Worbsped und da haben sie irgendwie ihr Militär ähm quasi so als Unterstützendes.
Element mit eingebaut. Das hatte dann sowas zur Folge wie.
Okay, um jetzt hier die nächste Stufe zu machen, brauchen wir irgendwie ein neues Gerät. Wir brauchen eine neue Maschine.
Irgendeinen großen, dicken, fetten Apparat, der dann was weiß ich aus Kanada durch die halbe Republik transportiert werden muss, der muss ja dann irgendwie auch ankommen.
Haben die da so Dinger gebracht, dass sie dann halt einfach so ein
Militärkonvoi haben ausrücken lassen, der diesen Transporter, der diese Maschine dahin gebracht hat, einfach mal quer durchs Land begleitet haben. Der ist dann irgendwie tausende von Kilometern gefahren, aber hat nicht eine einzige rote Ampel gesehen, einfach durchgebrettert
Weißt du? So, wir brauchen jetzt diese Maschine mal ganz schnell und dann rum sind die da einfach mit. Militärischer Begleitung äh durchmarschiert. Keine Ahnung, was da alles noch äh passiert ist, aber das gehört da auf jeden Fall mit dazu.
Würde man das mit Bundeswehrbegleitung äh machen, würde der LKW wahrscheinlich viermal so lange brauchen.
Mich erinnern, wenn wir marschiert sind, äh zu sagen im Konvoi, dann galt halt dreißig KMH Höchstgeschwindigkeit so,
und äh ja da kommst du halt pro Tag nicht so weit, wenn du irgendwie nur dreißig fahren äh äh darfst. Ja äh.
Aber ja, das klingt doch ganz gut. Ich glaube, ich habe sogar auch von einem dritten äh Impfstoff irgendwie gehört äh sogar noch jetzt heute oder so. Äh der auch.
Es ist noch so einiges äh unterwegs. Vielleicht nochmal ein paar vergleichende Daten jetzt zwischen diesen beiden Wirkstoffen. Also habe ja schon gesagt, selbes Prinzip ist es ja, ne, aber so im Detail,
ändern die sich, also bei Björn Tech ist mit drei Wochen Abstand diese zweite Dosis äh Impfstoff vergeben worden. Zweite Dos ist auch bei moderner erforderlich, allerdings mit vier Wochen Abstand. Moderner hat aber eine höhere Dosierung,
Ungefähr so dreimal so viel. Da muss man halt mal sehen,
wie dann eben diese produzierten Mengen sich äh niederschlagen, also von der Verfügbarkeit her Biontech geht ja davon aus, dass sie dieses Jahr noch fünfundzwanzig Millionen ähm Dosierungen oder Behandlungen heißt das dann, also fünfundzwanzig Millionen.
Quasi pro. Also eine Behandlung ist sozusagen eine Verabreichung eines Impfstoffs in ausreichender Menge zweimal,
an eine Person so, also fünfundzwanzig Millionen
Personen letzten Endes. Nächstes Jahr sehen sie sich dann schon bei sechshundertfünfzig Millionen. Moderner startet etwas moderater mit zehn Millionen und sieht nächstes Jahr so je nachdem wie gut es läuft mit zweihundertfünfzig bis fünfhundert Millionen Behandlungen. Das sind auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen die.
Kandidaten für die westliche Welt, sag ich mal, ne? Wo jetzt sehr schnell mit viel Geld
was bewegt werden kann, weil dieses ganze wie wird dieser Impfstoff verteilt und wie wird da gelagert und transportiert und äh ja, du musst ja die Orte haben, du musst das Personal haben, et cetera. Das ist alles relativ aufwendig,
Deswegen denke ich mal, wird sich die Anwendung dieser Impfstoffe erstmal auf die wirklich wichtigen Bereiche,
in äh ja im im Westen, also USA, Europa äh Niederregen und vielleicht.
Gibt's auch einen Weg, äh möglichst viele andere Länder. Äh auch noch zu beteiligen. Da gibt's ja da entsprechende Kommissionen, weil sie jetzt im Einzelnen nicht so ganz genau.
Wichtig ist natürlich, dass vor allem, dass man die Leute in Krankenhäusern das ganze medizinische Personal bevorzugt, ähm, geimpft wird.
Ähm.
Mittlerweile hat dann Biontex sich aber auch nochmal gemeldet und hat äh bekannt gegeben, dass ihre Studie jetzt auch,
Die ausreichende Zahl von Fällen hatte, also äh vor einer Woche hieß es ja noch, wir haben irgendwie vierundneunzig Fälle und daraus können wir jetzt sozusagen schon mal was ablesen. Mittlerweile sind sie bei hundertsiebzig Fällen, hundertvierundsechzig brauchten sie, das heißt, sie haben jetzt die Zulassung,
Voraussetzung.
Theoretisch erreicht und angeblich sollen sie heute, Freitag, zwanzigster November in USA bereits Notfallzulassung beantragen. Hier geht's also gerade alles ganz schnell.
Außerdem haben sie äh auch bekannt gegeben, dass sie jetzt auch bei fünfundneunzig Prozent Wirksamkeit sind, also das mit den restlichen Fällen, die jetzt noch bekannt geworden sind, die Wirksamkeit sogar noch nach oben gegangen ist. Fünfundneunzig Prozent ist wirklich extrem guter Wert und der geht vor allem auch,
auch bei älteren Leuten, also auch bei Leuten, die älter als fünfundsechzig sind, äh gehen sie immer noch von der Wirksamkeit von vierundneunzig Prozent aus, also mehr oder weniger das Gleiche.
Ja. Dann gibt's noch gute Nachrichten, was die Immunität an sich betrifft.
Gab's 'ne Studie aus der Universität Freiburg, dann haben die irgendwie ein Institut, das entnahmen mich jetzt grade nicht parat habe und die haben ähm.
Nochmal ganz genau geschaut, wie es denn jetzt eigentlich so konkret gelaufen ist mit äh Antikörpern.
Et cetera bei Leuten, die halt in Corona Virus ähm Befall hatten.
Und die haben eigentlich auch ganz interessante Zahlen geliefert. Also sie haben verschiedene Sachen geschaut, also sie haben den Leuten Blut abgenommen, den meisten Leuten nur eine Probe, aber bei.
Achtunddreißig von hundertfünfundachtzig, diese insgesamt untersucht haben, haben sie auch mehrere Blutproben unternommen und haben halt geschaut, okay, ihr hattet schon mal Corona. Was ist denn jetzt im Blut noch zu sehen.
Haben sich das eben ganz genau angeschaut und dann gibt's halt irgendwie diese Antikörper.
Die Alarm schlagen, dann gibt's diese B Zellen, die diese Antikörper erzeugen und dann gibt's halt noch diese zwei Arten von irgendwie Teezellen, die halt direkt auf die Zellen losgehen und die dann äh vernichten, die man ja vor allem haben will und die die neuen Impfstoffe ja auch,
erzogen und die Feststellung war, dass dieser Antikörper sehr lange durchhielten und dass es auch nach sechs bis acht Monaten.
Nur einen sehr geringen Rückgang gab bei diesen Leuten.
Und ähm es gab zwar bei den Testpersonen relativ große Unterschiede bei den Mengen, die sie so gefunden haben.
Führen das aber im Wesentlichen darauf zurück, dass.
Leute halt unter Umständen auch mehr oder weniger schwer infiziert waren. Auch bei diesen Teezellen gab's nur einen sehr geringen,
Rückgang und was man noch nicht so ganz genau weiß ist, warum diese B-Zellen, die diese Antikörper da produzieren, sogar noch zugenommen haben. Also wie auch immer in.
Insgesamt ist die Feststellung eigentlich die. Man kann davon ausgehen, dass eine Immunisierung.
Zumindest diese natürliche Immunisierung sehr lange hält.
Und ich denke, es gibt auch genug Anlass zu glauben, dass die Immunisierung, die durch die Impfstoffe hervorgerufen wird, auch entsprechend lange hält, weil letzten Endes das Gleiche ist, oder zumindest sein sollte.
Das klingt doch sehr erfreulich.
Ja demnächst wird's ähm.
Also Astra Cenica ist glaube ich äh noch auf der Liste, noch ein paar andere, die demnächst auch nochmal nachlegen werden, dann eben teilweise mit äh anderen, also auf diesen
denovieren, basierende Impfstoffe, das heißt, das Portfolio wird sich noch so ein bisschen vergrößern und das kann eigentlich auch ganz gut sein, weil
Am Ende kann man das auch einfach äh alles kombinieren und.
Dann müssen wir halt mal gucken, wie schnell das jetzt äh geht.
Ja, hoffen wir, dass es möglichst schnell geht.
Dann habe ich noch einen ganz kleinen äh Nachtrag, weil ich mir das selber, ehrlich gesagt, bisher auch noch nicht so richtig äh klar gemacht äh hatte. Ähm.
Ich verlinke hier so ein kleines Erklärbär Video zu diesen N fünfundneunzig Masken die ja so fünfundneunzig.
N fünfundneunzig heißt, weil sie halt fünfundneunzig Prozent der Stoffe irgendwie aufhalten sollen und ihr gegenüber diesen normalen OP Masken als.
Ja die zu bevorzugende Methode gelten. Mir war bloß irgendwie nicht so ganz klar, warum eigentlich.
Also warum sind die eigentlich besser als diese OP Masken? Weißt du das.
Na ja die halten halt einfach wesentlich mehr Partikel zurück.
Ja klar, aber warum? Und äh das wurde mir irgendwie in diesem Video so ein bisschen äh klar, sollte sich jeder mal äh anschauen. Der Trick ist der
dass äh hier so ein physikalischer Effekt äh benutzt wird, dass eben diese Kunststofffasern, die da teilweise mit eingearbeitet sind, in einem gewissen Maße auch äh magnetisierbar sind. Das geht also nicht nur mit äh Metallen,
und dass eben diese kleinsten Partikel deshalb so gut eingefangen werden, weil während sie dadurch schwebend quasi von diesen Fasern angezogen werden.
Und äh das führt eben dazu. Und ich habe mir jetzt auch mal so N fünfundneunzig Masken gekauft.
Gibt's ja mittlerweile auch relativ günstig zu kriegen und ja, die haben finde ich nochmal so ein.
Vorteil gegenüber diesen normalen OP Masten, dass er halt nicht einfach mal so eben links und rechts so so schnell Löcher entstehen durch diese Faltung, sondern dass sie einfach sehr viel besser aufliegen.
Na ja und wenn sie dann eben auch noch besser rausfiltern, kann man sich, glaube ich, in bestimmten Umgebungen, wo man sich sonst nicht so wohl fühlt, äh, nochmal bisschen besser schützen und wohler fühlen.
Also sie müssten.
Eigentlich die äh Zeit äh muss sagen ungefähr verzwanzigfachen, die du dich äh infektiöser Umgebung aufhalten kannst. So.
Mein hundertprozentig sind die halt auch nicht, aber ja.
Fünfundneunzig prozentig. Serge Mobbers.
Ja, dann vielleicht noch ein paar Worte zu Schnelltest, dann gab's ein paar interessante äh Sachen. Sagt der eigentlich Space Carin etwas.
Sagte Karin etwas? Caren ist so ein bisschen äh das Synonym für.
Nicht unbedingt weibliche, sondern so generell so Menschen, die es nicht checken, so und die irgendwie.
Auf die falschen Demos gehen und sich der Meinung sind, sie müssten sich diesen ganzen Maßnahmen nicht anschließen und für sie würden ja andere Regeln gelten und überhaupt.
So und ähm was ist Space Caren.
Keine Ahnung. Was ist Basecaren.
Carries ist der neue neue ähm,
für Elon Musk, der sich nämlich der sich total der sich irgendwie auch noch wie Corona Virus äh eingefangen hat, beziehungsweise äh bisschen unklar, was die Situation ist. Er hat irgendwie mehrere Tests gemacht.
Positiv und negative Tests beko.
Ja, ja, da dachte ich auch nur, immer der Typ hat, es ist ja noch ganz äh.
Ja, der ist
irgendwie genial in dem was er eigentlich tut, aber alles andere und auch diese Chorona-Krise, die scheint ihm dann doch schon eher hart zuzusetzen oder sie hat, glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe
für irgendein Event dann halt diese Schnelltest gemacht und dann gab's halt irgendwie, na ja, dann ist ja sozusagen ein bisschen Opfer der der falsch positiv Rate geworden und durfte sich dann vom Internet erklären lassen, was denn sozusagen Schnelltest überhaupt sind und äh
ja, was man so bisher darüber weiß und dass sie eben auch nur für einen bestimmten Zeitraum äh greifen und so weiter und so weiter und so weiter. Und irgendjemand warft dann auf,
Twitter irgendwie in so einer lustigen Formulierung, den Begriff Space Carren und wir sind alle haben sich komplett weggelegt, mich äh eingeschlossen.
Wenn das auch gut. Also.
Ich mein was ist denn jetzt draus geworden? Hat er denn jetzt, was hat er denn jetzt also.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich hab's nicht verfolgt ehrlich gesagt.
Weil weil an sich würde ich sagen, wenn du, ich meine vier Schnelltests machst, so am selben Tag oder.
Innerhalb von zwei Tagen so und du hast zwei negative und zwei positive drunter, dann äh würde ich sagen, dann bist du positiv,
so weil,
soweit ich weiß, äh, haben diese Schnelltests jetzt keine besonders hohe falsch positiven Rate, die haben äh äh eventuell äh kriegen die halt die Infektion nicht mit, wenn du das nicht richtig
durchführst. Also es ist eher eine falsch negativen Rate, oder?
Na gut, das hängt natürlich davon ab, wann du das äh äh machst.
Und tatsächlich gibt's gerade von Drostens Team von der Charité dazu eine frisch veröffentlichte äh Studie, die jetzt glaube ich auch alles noch präpent äh ist, ne? Wie das so ist
alle auf dem Markt verfügbaren, also nicht nur er sein Team, äh, alle auf dem Markt verfügbaren,
Schnelltests mal so richtig durchgetestet hat, also die Tests getestet hat, wie gut denn das jetzt hier tatsächlich eigentlich funktioniert
und ich bin nicht besonders gut im Lesen von solchen biochemischen äh Studien, aber soweit ich das äh meine diesem,
Dokumente entnehmen zu können
ist die Qualität einiger Tests gut und dem von manchen Tests sogar sehr gut. Und auch andere Studien äh sagen halt auch ganz klar bei diesen ganzen Antigentests, die können halt schon helfen, aber man muss sie halt einfach klar machen
dass es hier da eher darum geht, dass man eben schnell arbeiten kann und äh dass man also schnell ein Ergebnis
hat und dass man eben oft testen muss, weil eben das haben wir ja auch schon ein paar Mal besprochen,
Schnelltests einfach nur für einen bestimmten Zeitraum wirklich gut greifen, also wirklich nur die unmittelbare Infektion widerspiegeln.
Mhm. Aber das ist im Grunde genommen auch das, was man haben will und jetzt nochmal auf Space Carren äh zurückzukommen, so.
Ja
Ich meine, wenn ich zwei positive Schnelltests habe, dann kann man eigentlich davon ausgehen mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit, äh dass ich infiziert bin. Und nicht nur infiziert, sondern infikiös. Ja.
Ja und mit welcher äh er jetzt das versucht hat. Ich meine, das ist ja ersetzt schon fast Trumpsche Qualität, muss ich sagen.
Na ja auf jeden Fall ist er nicht sein gestorben, dass das schon mal ganz gut für ihn, aber ich glaube der Bevölkerung könnte mit Schnelltest immer noch geholfen werden.
Gut äh zum Schluss nochmal ganz kleine Sache zur Corona äh Warnapp. Da gab's einen.
Eine Umfrage in der Schweiz in Österreich und in Deutschland.
Warum denn die Leute diese App nicht installieren? Also was sozusagen ihre Gründe sind, warum sie das sie nicht installieren wollen.
Weil.
Sind ja nicht so viele Gründe eingefallen, ne? Man kann natürlich jetzt tausend Mal argumentieren mit, na ja, aber es hilft ja nicht oder funktioniert nicht so
ja genau, das hat aber was damit zu tun, wie viele Leute es installieren so und wenn man sich sozusagen genau aus diesem Grund dagegen entscheidet zu installieren dann.
Denn das ist eine Self-Full-Filling Profession an der Stelle. Aber mich haben die Antworten haben mich so ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Also die meistgegebene Antwort war und zwar mittel ich das jetzt so ein bisschen, das waren Schweiz Deutschland, Österreich, so bisschen unterschiedlich, aber auch nicht so sehr. Hauptgrund war so aus Datenschutzgründen. Das war so.
Einunddreißig bis achtunddreißig Prozent.
Wo ich halt sagen muss.
Verfehlt. Also das ist äh sozusagen das das Thema ist durch, also da muss man sich wirklich keine Gedanken machen. Aber der zweitmeistgenannte Grund war die Abschützt mich nicht.
Neben so Sachen wie interessiert mich nicht, Corona Piros wird zur Überwachung missbraucht und,
weil es nicht verpflichtend ist und äh was wir da noch in meinem Umfeld gibt es nur wenig Kowit-Fälle. Also das äh okay, gut, Ausreden, aber was mich wirklich ein bisschen schockiert hat, war so dieses die Abschützt mich nicht.
Und ein bisschen bisschen dran verzweifelt, habe das dann irgendwie auch getwittert, meinte so, irgendwie, wann, wann ist uns eigentlich dieses wir abhanden gekommen, was hier irgendwie,
äh offensichtlich nicht mehr im Vordergrund zu äh stehen scheint, ne? Mal ganz unabhängig davon, ob die App jetzt wirklich all das leisten kann, was was bei uns gerne erhoffen würden und so weiter, ist eine ganz andere Debatte. Aber sowas überhaupt als Argumentation
äh zu bringen. Das ist die App ja einen selber nicht schützt. Und was deswegen ja nicht,
bräuchte oder nicht deswegen nicht machen würde, ja? Es ist immer nur um, um, um ich ich gehe. Weil ich sehe das ganz anders. Du wahrscheinlich auch, so.
Ja, die unmittelbare Funktion ist nicht ein Schutz, weil wenn wir uns mit einem Smartphone vor Viren schützen könnten, das wäre ja was ganz Tolles, ne?
Aber am Ende ist es so, äh natürlich schützt es auch einen selber, weil in dem Moment, wo man dazu beiträgt, die Infektionsrisiken insgesamt zu senken, senkt man natürlich damit auch die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es dann auch irgendwann zu mir kommt.
Selbst wenn ich jetzt sozusagen an einem Prozess äh teilgenommen habe, ich werde gewarnt, aber ich hab's nicht, ja? Dann heißt es ja noch lange nicht,
dass dass mich das nicht irgendwie auch noch,
hintenrum wieder erreichen kann über andere Leute, so. Also jede Warnkette, an der ich in irgendeiner Form produktiv teilnehme und verhindere, dass Leute eine Infektion weitertragen, kann einfach hilfreich sein.
Und mich. Mich stört das und vielleicht sollte ich nicht überrascht sein, vielleicht muss man mittlerweile schon mit so einem pessimistischen Blick in die Welt gehen und sagen, alle doof.
Denkt nur noch an sich, aber ich will das auch irgendwie nicht, also ich will nicht sagen, ich will's nicht glauben, meine.
Ich denke immer noch eine andere Wahrnehmung zu haben und dann überrascht mich sowas immer.
Ja. Ähm ich meine es gibt.
Immer wieder so Momente, wo man äh gerne an der Menschheit verzweifeln möchte, so äh,
ja vom US-Wahlergebnis,
angefangen so, wo du sagst, ich meine, wie kann man, wie wie können irgendwie dann doch,
ja ein Viertel der Bevölkerung über ein Viertel der Bevölkerung in den USA und fast die Hälfte aller Wähler einen Präsidenten mit so einer Performance äh wieder wählen so,
Aber gut, das ist Politik, aber lange so eine ganz einfache Sache, wo ich auch dachte, was äh äh die die
Sache hat jetzt mit Corona Gabel erst mal gar nichts zu tun, aber ich weiß nicht, ob du das gelesen hast mit den ähm,
Haustieren, das halt schwarze Haustiere einfach seltener genommen werden aus dem Tierheim.
Und angeblich aus ja also auf,
offiziell die Tierarztmitarbeiter sagten, ja weil äh äh Leute glauben, dass halt schwarze Katzen Unglück bringen oder schwarze Tiere Unglück bringen?
So. Meine Tochter meinte, oh nee, Hanni, heutzutage ist das wahrscheinlich eher,
nicht so, also so, aber gläubig sind jetzt die jüngeren Leute nicht, aber äh schwarze Tiere kann man halt so schlecht auf Instagram posten. Die Fotos äh sehen halt für Social
einfach nicht so gut aus.
Oh
Und ja das äh wie gesagt war so ein Moment äh so und auch nur denkst, ja, okay, eine Menschheit äh halt.
Was es auch immer ist äh so äh ja äh es sind,
einfach Leute, die aus Gründen Entscheidungen fällen, die ja äh für andere Leute überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar äh sind.
Dann könnte jetzt sich da auch also es gibt da gewisse Thesen, warum dem so ist, aber erstmal sagen, ja.
Andere Leute denken anders und wir sind halt,
als Menschen alle nicht so die rationalen Wesen, die wir gerne sein möchten. Ähm wir sind halt dann irgendwie immer noch in unseren Reflexen äh gefangen äh in.
Und interpretieren unterschiedliche Signale halt einfach nicht so wie es in der modernen Welt besser wäre, wenn wir sie denn interpretieren. Das wäre halt ja,
Und da haben wir jetzt auch als soziale Wesen äh jetzt äh zum Beispiel uns wahrscheinlich von Freunden anstecken, weil wir halt
Fronten nicht zutrauen, dass sie Corona haben könnten und uns anstecken würden und deswegen sogar halt bei Freunden dann auf Masken verzichten, weil
unhöflich zu sein halt schlimmer ist erscheint in dem Moment als sich zu infizieren.
Und äh ja also weil es gibt tausende solcher äh Effekte so auch,
sich im Bereich jetzt Kriminalität und Kriminalitätsbekämpfung und warum begehen Leute Verbrechen und so und das ist alles nicht logisch. Also vielleicht muss man einfach sagen, okay äh.
Auf dreißig Prozent muss man verzicht.
Wenn jemand vernünftig und logisch handelt und agiert, dann ist das eine anders als äh angenehme, positive Ausnahme äh würdigen und nicht frustriert sein, wenn äh ja.
Leute einfach völlig irre Dinge tun. Man macht wahrscheinlich jeder von uns auch dann und wann so einfach,
alle Fakten beiseite äh schieben, vielleicht nicht dann in den Fällen, wo es andere Leute machen, aber so ich kann mir ja angucke, zum Beispiel Motorrad fahren, also,
Ist halt äh man da jetzt rein rational rangehen würde. Äh so würde man auch sagen, ist viel zu gefährlich. Ja.
Irre.
Downloadzahlen steigen auf jeden Fall etwas,
Ja, es ist alles noch nicht äh besonders gut und auch die notwendigen Änderungen an Anpassungen werden wahrscheinlich alle noch so ein bisschen brauchen. Mal gucken, vielleicht ist es fertig, wenn wenn der Impfstoff an alle verteilt ist, äh sein,
war auf jeden Fall die Mühe wert, nehme ich mal an. Ähm ist ja auch jetzt nicht so, dass niemand davon gewarnt worden wäre bisher. Also ein paar Leuten hat's mindestens geholfen.
Und müssen wir mal schauen wie das so weitergeht. Wir sind jetzt glaube ich am Ende würde ich sagen dieser Sendung.
Ja, ja, ja, vielleicht noch eine noch eine kleine,
Endrunde mit Ausblick, wie siehst du denn das jetzt so, wie der wird denn das jetzt so die nächsten zwei Monate und Weihnachten weitergehen? Was ist denn deine Erwartung.
Na ja, also als als chronisch nicht religiöser Mensch ähm muss ich
zugeben, dass ich äh auch mit weiteren sechs Wochen Lokdown jetzt nicht so das große Problem habe, auch wenn's mich äh ein bisschen in meiner Interviewtätigkeit einschränkt, aber so persönlich habe ich jetzt nicht so sehr viel davon
zu befürchten, dass es natürlich nicht unbedingt bei allen Leuten so. Ich glaube, dieses Weihnachten ist so so eine heilige Kuh und deswegen ähm wär's.
Wahrscheinlich ganz klug gewesen, wenn wir härtere Maßnahmen haben, aber ich gehe einfach mal davon aus, der November ist durch, davon bin ich aber sowieso schon ausgegangen, also wir werden jetzt einfach die nächsten zwei Wochen
keine nennenswerten Lockerungen sehen und ehrlich gesagt, ich will von diesem Wort auch nichts hören, sondern wir werden eigentlich eher darüber nachdenken müssen, wie sich noch Sachen
bisschen verschärfen lassen, aber wir hatten ja schon mal so, ne? So viel wird er wahrscheinlich nicht geschehen. Also müssen wir wahrscheinlich mit diesem Status quo
leben, der sich, wenn ich die Zahlen jetzt richtig interpretiere, ähm so einpendelt, dass so na ja äh Glück haben in einer Woche, die Todeszahlen
vielleicht wieder ein bisschen zurückgehen. So, aber in zwei Wochen dann
Immer noch fünfzig Leute oder dreißig Leute pro Tag sterben und das ist eigentlich auch immer noch nicht so schön.
Von daher denke ich mal, wird das noch bis in den Dezember reingehen. So und Weihnachtsgeschenke solltet ihr lieber jetzt schon kaufen.
Ja
Und Weihnachtsmärkte absagen, Silvester absagen, das ist ja hier auch so eine Diskussion, dass man jetzt einfach mal äh diese Böllerei in diesem Jahr einfach mal komplett sein lässt. Gibt's dann zwar gleich wieder die nächste Industrie, die schreit und äh irgendwie.
Durchgefüttert werden muss, da wird's dann ein bisschen schwierig mit den fünfundsiebzig Prozent Einnahmenersatz im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr. Wer aber ein Boltmove und ehrlich gesagt auch die Knallerei kann ich persönlich total verzichten sowieso. Ich finde das,
einfach.
So wie es gemacht wird ohnehin nicht sonderlich kulturell äh wertvoll und das halt einfach alle Krankenhäuser dann auch noch irgendwie im Stundentakt äh mit hunderten von Leuten beschickt werden in dieser Situation. Das ist einfach, geht einfach nicht.
Nee, denke ich, denke ich auch. Also bei uns laufen jetzt gerade die Weihnachts- und Silvesterplanungen und das wird dann doch.
Alles im sehr kleinen Kreis äh stattfinden und ja.
Ja, vor allem, wir haben, wir leben ja schon seit Monaten in so einem Weihnachtsgefühl, so wie wir irgendwie uns zu Hause äh einmummeln. Was was wollt ihr denn da Weihnachten jetzt noch groß machen? Verschiebt Weihnachten auf Februar oder März ist völlig egal.
Die Amerikaner haben jetzt auch noch Senks gewinn.
Ja, Jesus ist das egal, nimmt Truthahn auch.
Da muss man sich jetzt glaube ich einfach mal von trennen, also was was sind diese Rituale jetzt noch wert, wenn sie uns potentiell einfach nur umbringen und eure Familienmitglieder dann auch.
Also.
Ja, ja, also ich bin gespannt darauf, was nächsten Mittwoch äh passiert, wenn äh sagen dieses neue, längerfristige Framework äh dann veröffentlicht werden soll, wo dann drinsteht.
Ich vermute ist
sagen so konkrete Richtwerte und Maßnahmen, wenn Institenz, höher oder niedriger als und so weiter dann äh die uns dann lockern äh und sonst verschärfen. Sowas,
in der Art äh äh erwarte ich mir halt, sondern sozusagen so ein Maßnahmenkatalog, der mehr oder weniger dann
unabhängig ist äh von politischen Entscheidungen, sondern wo man sich dann orientiert einfach an
bestimmten Werten und Gegebenheiten und äh dass also ich denke am Ende wird dann äh Merkel wieder äh schon das kriegen, was sie halt wollte, leider.
Nur Wochen zu spät und man fragt sich auch, äh warum wir dieses Ding nicht schon vor Monaten, also warum sowas nicht schon vor Monaten äh ausgearbeitet und in Kraft gesetzt, weil andere Länder haben,
sowas. Also sind da deutlich äh äh weiter oder differenzierter, was so politische Maßnahmenkataloge.
Angeht und äh ja äh ich meine äh also ich ich befürchte und.
Bisher läuft's halt leider so. Also ich befürchte, dass erstmal nicht allzu viel passieren äh wird und weil das Wetter auch noch weiterhin gut sein wird, was halt ganz gut ist, wird's jetzt erstmal keine
wahrscheinlich keine neue Explosion der Zahlen geben, sondern die werden so weiter rumdümpeln auf dem Niveau wie sie jetzt sind, aber irgendwann wird's kalt werden. Das Wetter bleibt nicht so, wie es jetzt ist. Und irgendwann,
im Dezember äh so äh werden die Zahlen dann halt
nochmal in die Höhe schießen, wenn's dann plötzlich richtig kalt wird so und dann rechne ich damit, äh, wird's ja äh auch nochmal irgendwann den totalen
Logdown äh geben. So, wann? Keine Ahnung, das hängt wie gesagt auch vom Wetter ab
aber so ja ich sehe nicht, dass es besser wird bis Weihnachten oder vor Januar oder Februar, sondern es bleibt so und irgendwann.
Äh kommt nochmal äh so ein richtiger Einschlag.
Der Weihnachtsmann mit der Impfdosis.
Ja, das ist das Selbstbewusst.
Was mich eigentlich am meisten stört an diesen ganzen Nichtmaßnahmen oder Maßnahmen. Hier in Berlin ist es so,
Berichte drüber gelesen. Die Leute vom Ordnungsamt, die drehen alle am Rad.
Die sagen, es ist einfach alles überhaupt nicht mehr überprüfbar, jede Woche ändert sich irgendein Detail, irgendeine Ausnahmeregelung.
Und man kann einfach niemanden mehr irgendwas sagen. Sie sind auch teilweise dann nicht in der Lage, das umzusetzen, weil dann irgendwie in ihrer Software
der jeweilige Vorfall überhaupt nicht abgebildet ist und von daher überhaupt nicht festgestellt werden kann und von daher auch am Gegenmaßnahmen oder beziehungsweise Bestrafung oder Sanktionen nicht eingeleitet werden können. Und ganz ehrlich,
wir durch, weil wir jetzt hier irgendwie einmal die Woche uns das gegenseitig immer wieder runterrattern und uns wahrscheinlich auch schon äh achttausendmal wiederholt haben bei allem. Wir haben da irgendwie so so halbwegs eine Ahnung, was gerade so die Maßnahmen sind,
aber so richtig wissen, tun wir es auch nicht. Vor zwei, drei Wochen hatte ich glaube ich mal auf diesem Zettel aus Irland verwiesen, diese Matrix,
ein ganz einfaches System, das haben viele, viele Länder mittlerweile. Da steht einfach, es gibt fünf Warnlevel.
Fünf ist das Schlimmste und eins ist die meiste Lockerung. Und dann hast du.
Einträge für verschiedene Dinge. Was es mit Hochzeiten, was ist mit Partys, was mit Veranstaltungen, was ist mit Arbeiten, was ist mit ÖPNV, was ist mit damit damit damit damit? Das heißt, jede Kategorie, von der man weiß, dass sie in irgendeiner Form von
Maßnahmen betroffen sein kann, hast du einfach so eine Matrix und da steht drin wenn dieser Level ist,
dann dieser Einschränkung. Wenn dieser Level ist, diese Einschränkung,
ein Zettel hat jeder in der Tasche und du sagst Mittwoch ist drei oder wissen alle Bescheid.
Stattdessen haben wir so einen Wildwuchs aus
Ausnahmen und weiß es nicht und ja gilt eigentlich aber erst ab nächsten Dienstag und aber nicht in dem Landkreis, sondern da irgendwie erst am Mittwoch. Also damit kann ja auch keiner arbeiten,
Also es ist einfach auch ein ganz praktische Problematik, was auch immer man gerade beschließt. Die Art und Weise, wie das kommuniziert wird,
ist unterirdisch.
Ja, das war's aber auch. Äh ich meine, das war's aber auch, was ich meinte mit äh dass andere Länder äh das wesentlich besser ausgearbeitet haben. Und es bleibt zu hoffen, dass wir dann nächsten Mittwoch dann
auch irgendwas in der Art äh kriegen, äh wo äh ja das dann klar äh hervor,
geht so und gut am Ende.
Ja, braucht man aber im Moment nicht viel zu wissen, es ist einfach bleibt zu Hause und geht nur raus, wenn ihr denn wirklich,
unbedingt müsst, wenn ihr einen guten, guten Grund dafür habt, äh so und wenn ihr draußen seid, irgendwie passt auf.
Ja ähm keine Partys.
Äh und wenn man das meistet eh äh zu im Moment, aber äh ja und ich denke einfach die Zahl der Kontakte minimieren und äh ansonsten die,
bei notwendigen Kontakten äh ausreichende Schutzmaßnahmen äh.
Ist das ist das Ding? Da braucht man dann, glaube ich, jetzt eigentlich gar nicht im Detail zu wissen, gut am Ende des Tages, äh ich meine.
Will ich natürlich kann ich mich dann so nah wie möglich an das gesetzlich zulässige heranarbeiten,
ja. Aber ich glaube, dass es in dem Fall einfach nicht angeraten,
sozusagen zu gucken nach dem Motto okay äh was kann ich denn jetzt gerade noch tun, was ist denn so die maximale Zahl der Leute, die ich jetzt einladen kann und die lade ich dann auch ein,
ja weil oh ich welche zwei kann ich denn jetzt noch einladen, weil ich hab ja noch zwei frei. Das ist glaub ich nicht äh.
Das Ziel dieser Maßnahmen ist, dass man sich nie infiziert. Also infiziert euch einfach nicht.
Manifiziert sich einfach, wenn man in der Nähe von anderen Menschen ist. So, bleibt einfach bei denen, die ihr jetzt schon habt so oder lasst die sein, wenn die doof sind und wählt euch zumindest nicht alle zehn Minuten neue und einfach.
Ja, ich meine, gut, es gibt natürlich leider.
Einen ganzen Haufen von Leuten, die halt Kontakte nicht so richtig minimieren können, sei es jetzt Lehrer an Schulen oder äh ja.
Oder als als Eltern von Kinder von schulpflichtigen Kindern zum Beispiel oder in manchen Jobs so.
Ein gemeinsamer Freund von uns hat's auf Twitter vorhin sehr schön ausgedrückt, was mit den Schulen ist, so, ja, die Schulen sind offen, so, aber wir machen ja diese ganzen anderen Maßnahmen auch deshalb, damit sie offen bleiben können.
So ähm ja äh da hätte ich dann fast drauf geantwortet ähm ja so allerdings hätten wir dann äh deutlich früher damit anfangen.
Das steht vollkommen, außer.
Zu erreichen, so jetzt
ist der Zug einfach abgefahren, auch wenn's viele nicht wahrhaben wollen. Das war im Übrigen auch der Grund, warum dann am Montag nichts beschlossen wurde, weil am Montag war es noch so, dass es ein bisschen mehr Hoffnung gab, dass,
es vielleicht wirken könnte, ja? So äh und äh aber seit Montag, also in diesen fünf Tagen
hat sich das einfach verfestigt. Ich meine der, der neue Rekord heute trotz zurückgegangener Tests mehr positive,
Tests als je zuvor absolut, ja?
So das spricht halt einigermaßen klare Bände und Montag sind die Zahlen ja auch immer niedrig. So da ja und insofern ja.
Ich denke, irgend irgendwann werden alle äh zur Vernunft kommen, wird die Politik auch einsehen äh so, aber dann leider viel zu spät. So, leider viel zu spät und äh.
Ich äh ja habe keine gute Laun.
Der Westen ist auf jeden Fall äh kann sich das sein, sein, sein, seine kulturelle Hochnäsigkeit und seine Vorstellung der Überlegenheit,
bei dem Rest so auf jeden Fall mal komplett schenken irgendwie bei der Nummer haben wir uns einfach mal schon durchgehend äh blamiert. Es äh war's dann, glaube ich, erstmal hier mit Weitchen.
Na gut.
Also da ist ja also von Supremacy ist da gerade mal.
Die Rede.
Aber Leute nicht vergessen, gute Laune behalten ist auf jeden Fall wichtig. Man kann ja auch in diesen Zeiten noch äh kreative Dinge tun und wenn ihr äh keine Podcast aufnimmt, macht er halt irgendwie was anderes.
Ich habe auf jeden Fall ähm meinen Spaß und ich hoffe, ihr habt den auch und wir werden das schon irgendwie alles äh durchkriegen und ansonsten wird das Problem einfach weggeimpft.
Gut, dann sagen wir tschüss, bis bald, bis nächste Woche.